GOING TO GO AHEAD AND START THE
MEETING. LET ME JUST FIRST SAY,
I WELCOME WELCOME TO MY FIRST
GAVEL DOWN FOR, UH, B MP, AND
I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE AND I'VE
HAD A CHANCE OVER THE LAST FEW
DAYS TO GET TO KNOW THE STAFF
REALLY EXCITED TO GET TO WORK
WITH THIS TEAM. AND ALL OF YOU.
TODAY AND MOVING FORWARD. SO UH,
BE PATIENT WITH ME HERE. WE'LL
WORK OUR WAY THROUGH IT ALL
TOGETHER. TODAY'S HEARING FOR
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WILL COME TO ORDER
AND I WANT TO JUST LET EVERYBODY
KNOW THAT THE, UH, ISSUES
SURROUNDING OUR OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSING SYSTEM IMPACTS SO MANY
HARD WORKING PEOPLE. THAT'S WHY
SENATOR ROTH PREVIOUS CHAIR
DECIDED THAT THIS WOULD BE AN
IMPORTANT HEARING TO HAVE AND I
AGREE WITH HIM HAPPY TO BE HERE
TODAY. TO SEE IT THROUGH. IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE FOCUS ON THE
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT. THAT MAY
EXIST TODAY AS A RESULT OF THE
STEPS THAT WE REQUIRE FOLKS TO
TAKE JUST TO DO THEIR JOB IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ALL HAVE, UH
THE EXPERIENCE INCREASE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE CONNECTED
SYSTEMS PROVIDE FOR PATIENTS AND
FOR THE PUBLIC FOR ALL THAT WE
SERVE IN EVERY INDUSTRY. TODAY'S
HEARING WILL LOOK AT SOME OF
THOSE THINGS. WHERE THERE MAY BE
SETTINGS AND SERVICES THAT
LICENSE CENSURE PORTABILITY
HELPS FILL GAPS. HOW WE'RE GONNA
ADDRESS THAT. HOW A COMPACT
MIGHT ADDRESS THAT, AS WE TALK
TODAY ABOUT PATHWAYS TO
EMPLOYMENT WITH A FOCUS ON WHAT
THE INTERSTATE LICENSES OR
COMPACT MODEL MEANS FROM A
VARIETY OF PERSPECTIVES. I DO
WANNA THANK OUR PANELISTS. TODAY
WILL BE QUICK AND TRY TO GET
THROUGH EVERYBODY, BUT WE ALSO
WANNA BE THOROUGH. WANNA MAKE
SURE WE HAVE GOOD INFORMATION
AND THAT AT THE END OF THIS
HEARING AS WE LOOK TO THE
LEGISLATION THAT WILL ADDRESS
LATER THIS YEAR. UH, THAT THIS
HEARING HELPS US TO, UM HAVE
BETTER FOUNDATIONAL INFORMATION
AS WE LOOK TO MAKE DECISIONS IN
THIS AREA OF LAW FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND BETTER SERVICE
AS MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE
BEFORE WE START WITH OUR FIRST
PANEL BECAUSE IT'S SO UNUSUAL TO
HAVE A SWITCH LIKE THIS RIGHT
BEFORE A HEARING. I JUST WOULD
LIKE TO GIVE SENATOR ROTH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS AND SOME INTRODUCTORY
COMMENTS ABOUT HOW WE GOT HERE.
SO RIGHT. WELL, THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. I'M JUST DELIGHTED TO BE
ALLOWED TO PARTICIPATE AND THANK
YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY. OK? ALL RIGHT.
WELL, THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY TO YOU, SENATOR ROTH THAT,
UM I THINK THAT THIS WAS A GOOD
CALL. THIS WAS A GOOD CALL
BECAUSE THIS BODY IS GOING TO BE
ASKED TO MAKE DECISIONS IN THIS
AREA, AND IT'S GOOD TO HAVE THE
INFORMATION THAT HELPS INFORM
THOSE DECISIONS. AND THANKS TO
MY COLLEAGUES WHO ALL MADE TIME
TO COME FOR THE HEARING TODAY, I
APPRECIATE YOU. ALL RIGHT. READY
TO START. YEAH OK, ALRIGHT.
WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM OUR FIRST
SPEAKER WHO'S GONNA BE WITH US
ON ZOOM. UH HIS NAME IS DÂN
LOGSDON. HE'S THE DIRECTOR OF
THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR
INTERSTATE COMPACTS. WITH THE
COUNCIL OF STATE GOVERNMENT
CENTER OF INNOVATION, NOT FROM
CALIFORNIA, SO APPEARING
ELECTRONICALLY WITH US HERE. MR
LOGSDON. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. THANK YOU, UH, CHAIR ASHBY
. AND THANKS TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR HAVING ME, UH
TODAY I'M DÂN LAWSON I'M
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR INTERSTATE COMPACTS AT THE
COUNCIL OF STATE GOVERNMENTS.
UH, èC S¼ G IS A NONPARTISAN
MEMBERSHIP. ORGANIZATION OF
STATES, UH, WERE COMPOSED OF ALL
50 STATES, Dð èC AND THE FIVE U
S¼ TERRITORIES AND SERVE ALL
THREE BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT.
UH, THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR
INTERSTATE COMPACTS WAS FOUNDED
IN 2004. WE SERVE AS A TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE RESOURCE FOR STATES
AS THEY'RE CONSIDERING COMPACTS.
WE PROVIDE EDUCATION,
DEVELOPMENT AND ADMINISTRATION
SERVICES. WE WORK WITH
PROFESSIONAL MEMBERSHIP
ASSOCIATIONS, LEGISLATORS,
REGULATORS, ADMINISTRATORS, AND
THEN, UH, MOST OF OUR WORK RIGHT
NOW IS FOCUSED ON OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSURE COMPACTS. WE HAVE A
COOPER AGREEMENT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE TO DEVELOP
LICENSURE COMPACTS. UM AND WE'VE
HAD THAT SINCE, UH, 2020 SO JUST
BRIEFLY, UM, INTERSTATE COMPACTS
. GENERALLY THESE ARE
LEGISLATIVELY ENACTED AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN OR AMONG STATES. THERE'S
BILATERAL, REGIONAL AND NATIONAL
COMPACTS. THEY'RE A WAY FOR
STATES, UH, TO COOPERATIVELY
ADDRESS SHARED PROBLEMS. UH,
THESE ARE VERY POWERFUL, UH,
VERSATILE, PROVEN TOOLS. UM
COMPACTS HAVE BEEN AROUND. THEY
PREDATE THE FOUNDING OF THE
REPUBLIC. THERE WAS A COMPACT
CLAUSES IN THE ARTICLES OF
CONFEDERATION CERTAINLY IN THE U
S¼ CONSTITUTION. APPLICABLE
ACROSS MULTIPLE POLICY AREAS AND
AGAIN MOST OF THE WORK WITH
COMPACTS RIGHT NOW, ALTHOUGH NOT
ALL OF IT EXCLUSIVELY, UH, IS IN
THE OCCUPATIONAL LICENSE SPACE.
UM AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS,
YOU KNOW, IN RECENT YEARS,
STATES, UH, HAVE WANTED TO
RESPOND, UH TO, UH WEENER ISSUES
AND PORTABILITY ISSUES THEY WANT
TO REDUCE THE SOCIAL COST OF
LIFE INSURE, UH, THEY WANT AT
THE SAME TIME SAFEGUARD HEALTH
AND SAFETY, UH, IMPROVE
PORTABILITY, AND, MOST
IMPORTANTLY, IT PRESERVE STATE
SOVEREIGNTY. STATE AUTHORITY
OVER, UM, THE PRACTICE IN THEIR
STATE AND THEIR ABILITY TO
LICENSE PROFESSIONALS TO THE
STANDARDS, UH, THAT THEY SET. UM
THERE'S ALSO BEEN A LOT OF
INTEREST IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. A LOT OF SCRUTINY
ABOUT HOW STATES ARE LICENSING
SO AGAIN. THESE LICENSE OR
COMPACTS AREN'T OUTGROWTH OF
THAT. UM THE WAY THAT WE WORK TO
FACILITATE THE CREATION OF THESE
LEENER COMPACTS IS, YOU KNOW
IT'S A COLLABORATIVE,
TRANSPARENT PROCESS. UM THEY
ESTABLISH UNIFORM STANDARDS, BUT
THOSE ARE BASED OFF THE
STANDARDS AND UNIFORM STANDARDS
IN THE STATES. I I'LL TALK LATER
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, UM WHAT
PROFESSIONS MAYBE ARE BETTER
SUITED FOR INTERSTATE COMPACTS.
THEY DO CREATE A LYEN SYSTEM, UH
, THAT YOU USE FOR BOTH
DISCIPLINE AND THEN TO GET
PEOPLE INTO THE STATES UNDER
CERTAIN MODELS, UH, TO PRACTICE,
UH, IN THOSE REMOTE, COMPACT
MEMBER STATES, AND THEY'RE ALL
ADMINISTERED ALL MODERN COMPACTS
HAVE AN INTERSTATE COMMISSION
AND YOU KNOW THESE COMMISSIONS
ARE JUST THERE TO IMPLEMENT AND
ADMINISTER THE COMPACTS. THEY
CAN'T DICTATE POLICY TO THE
MEMBER STATES. THEY CAN'T
PROHIBIT A CERTAIN KIND OF
SERVICE OR PROCEDURE. THEY CAN'T
REQUIRE STATES TO AUTHORIZE A
CERTAIN KIND OF SERVICE OR
PROCEDURES. THEY'RE REALLY
HEMMED IN BY THE FOUR CORNERS OF
THE AGREEMENT. THERE ARE
CURRENTLY 16 OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSE OR COMPACTS OUT THROUGH
THE STATES FOR CONSIDERATION. UM
UH, THE OLDEST ONE OF THEM, UH,
THE MOST MATURE NURSING AND
MEDICINE. UH, THE PSYCHOLOGY?
UH, COMPACT, PAC, UM EACH OF
THOSE HAVE 40 OR MORE STATES.
I'LL SPARE YOU THE ENTIRE LIST.
WE'RE CURRENTLY WORKING ON A
COMPACT FOR RESPIRATORY THERAPY.
UH, AS PART OF OUR Dð Ó B
COOPER AGREEMENT. INFORM AND
FUNCTION. THEY'RE ALL THE SAME,
BUT THEY'RE ALSO, UH, SITUATED
DIFFERENTLY AND WORK A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY. UM YOU'VE GOT THE
MUTUAL RECOGNITION COMPACTS.
WHICH IS THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THEM AT EVERY ONE OF THEM.
BESIDES THE NURSING COMPACT THAT
OPERATES OFF OF YOUR HOME, STATE
OR QUALIFYING, STATE LICENSE. BE
RECOGNIZED TO GET YOU INTO ALL
THE OTHER COMPACT MEMBER STATES
THROUGH A MECHANISM. SO THE
NURSING COMPACT WORKS JUST LIKE
YOUR DRIVER'S LICENSE, AS DOES
COSMETOLOGY AND THE SOCIAL WORK.
COMPACT. UM YOU GET A MULTI
STATE LICENSE FROM YOUR HOME
STATE. UH, UH, BOARD AND THAT
ALLOWS YOU TO WORK IN THE OTHER
COMPACT MEMBER STATES. THE P Tð
COMPACT WAS THE FIRST COMPACT TO
DO THE SAME THING, BUT THEY THE
BOARDS WERE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
, YOU KNOW, AUTHORITY. THEY WERE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT, UM, YOU
KNOW, FRANKLY, YOU KNOW, REVENUE
LOSS POTENTIALLY FROM FROM FROM
THE COMPACT MECHANISM, ALTHOUGH
THE NURSING COMPACT UH UH,
BOARDS WILL TELL YOU THAT, YOU
KNOW, UH, THE IMPACT OF THEIR
FINANCIAL VIABILITY HAS BEEN, UH
DE MINIMIS. BUT STILL, IT'S ONE
THING TO HEAR THAT IT'S ANOTHER
THING TO POTENTIALLY LIVE IT, SO
THEY CREATED A PRIVILEGE TO
PRACTICE MODEL SO ESSENTIALLY
WORKS THE SAME. BUT YOU'RE
GETTING A COMPACT PRIVILEGE TO
WORK IN THE STATES THAT YOU WANT
TO WORK IN THAT. COMPACT MEMBER
STATES. SO JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
A VARIATION THERE, THEN YOU'VE
GOT TO EXPEDITE A LICENSE. YOUR
MODEL THAT'S THE INTERSTATE
MEDICAL LICENSE. YOUR COMPACT
AND THEN SAC IS ALSO A MUTUAL
RECOGNITION COMPACT, BUT IT'S UH
EXCLUSIVELY FOR TELEP
PSYCHOLOGY. SINCE 2016 STATES OF
RESPONDED BY ENACTING A NUMBER
OF THESE, THERE'S OVER 300
SEPARATE PIECES OF LEENER
COMPACT LEGISLATION THAT'S BEEN
ENACTED BY THE STATES IN 26
STATES HAVE ADOPTED SEVEN OR
MORE OF THESE LENGER COMPACTS.
THESE ARE SIMPLY A MEANS TO
PROVIDE ANOTHER PATHWAY FOR
LICENSED PROFESSIONAL TO
PRACTICE. UH IN OTHER COMPACT
MEMBER STATES, THEY DON'T
ELIMINATE OR CURTAIL OTHER
PORTABILITY PATHWAYS. THE
BIGGEST BENEFIT FOR
PRACTITIONERS IS THE AMOUNT OF
TIME REQUIRED TO BE ABLE TO WORK
IN OTHER COMPACT MEMBER STATES
AS OPPOSED TO OTHER PATHWAYS.
UH, ANOTHER BENEFIT FOR
PRACTITIONERS IS, YOU KNOW THE
REGULATORY CERTAINTY THAT THE
UNIFORMITY OF THE PROCESS,
WHEREAS YOU KNOW OTHER PATHWAYS.
PARTICULARLY YOU KNOW, LIKE A R
OR OR, UM, UM, LEENER
RECOGNITION BASED ON UH,
EXPEDITED LICENSE YOU'RE BASED
ON YOU KNOW, UH, ENDORSEMENT
FROM ANOTHER STATE. ALL STATES
ARE GONNA HANDLE THAT
DIFFERENTLY. EVEN SOME BOARDS IN
THE SAME STATE MIGHT HANDLE THAT
DIFFERENTLY. UM OTHER BENEFITS
FOR PRACTITIONERS, YOU KNOW, UM
IT REDUCES THE EFFORT NEEDED TO
MAINTAIN INDIVIDUAL LICENSES. SO
YOU KNOW YOU'RE ONE HOME, STATE
OR QUALIFYING. STATE LICENSE
ALLOWS YOU TO PRACTICE, UH, IN
OTHER COMPACT MEMBER STATES, SO
OBVIOUSLY YOU DON'T NEED TO
RETAIN MULTIPLE LICENSES. UH, IT
DOES IMPROVE PORTABILITY, AND IT
ALLOWS PRACTITIONERS TO LEVERAGE
TELEHEALTH. ALL THESE LICENSES
OR COMPACTS ALLOW FOR
TELEHEALTH. UM THE BENEFITS FOR
LICENSING BOARDS IS AGAIN STATES
RETAIN CONTROL OVER THEIR SCOPE.
UM COMPACTS FACILITATE THE
EXCHANGE OF LEENER DATA AND
DISCIPLINARY DATA TO THE COMPACT
DATA SYSTEM. UM AND THEY APPROVE
COOPER OPERATION AMONG STATE
BOARDS, ESPECIALLY WITH REGARD
TO PUBLIC PROTECTION. AND THEN
FOR, UH, PATIENTS OR CLIENTS.
YOU KNOW IT INCREASES ACCESS TO
CARE. UH ESPECIALLY THROUGH
TELEHEALTH. IT IMPROVES
CONTINUITY OF CARE, UH, PROMOTES
PRACTITIONER. DIVERSITY UH, AND
EXPANDS THE FULL PRACTITIONERS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE, AND, UH, IT
INCREASES THE ACCESS TO
SPECIALISTS. I MENTIONED OUR
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE. I KNOW THAT THERE'S
BEEN A NEW FEDERAL LAW THAT, UM
UH WAS PASSED LAST YEAR AROUND A
MILITARY SPOUSE LEISINGER. UH,
YOU KNOW, WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
IT'S. REALLY NOT GONNA ALLEVIATE
THE ISSUES FOR MILITARY SPOUSES.
UM WE'VE COMMUNICATED THAT, UH,
THIS LANGUAGE APPEARED IN THE
NATIONAL DEFENSE AUTHORIZATION
ACT A COUPLE OF TIMES BEFORE IT
WAS ENACTED. UH IT WAS PROMOTED
BY SENATOR MIKE LEE OF UTAH. UM
AND YOU KNOW, WE EXPRESSED OUR
CONCERNS THERE AS STATES HAVE
DONE A GOOD JOB RESPONDING TO
YOU KNOW THE NEEDS OF LICENSED,
UH MILITARY SPOUSES AND LICENSED
PROFESSIONS. UM EVERY STATE HAS
SOMETHING ON THE BOOKS TO HELP
MILITARY SPOUSES AND LICENSE
PROFESSIONS. THE ISSUE FOR
MILITARY SPOUSES IS, YOU KNOW
THEY'RE ALL DIFFERENT, RIGHT?
EVERY STATE'S GOT A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT REGIME ON HOW THEY
APPROACH THAT, UM, THE FEDERAL
LEGISLATION CERTAINLY TRIES TO
REMEDY THAT. UM BUT YOU KNOW
AGAIN, WE BELIEVE THAT IT'S
GONNA BE IMPLEMENTED
INCONSISTENTLY, AND WE'RE
ALREADY KIND OF THAT, UH, ACROSS
THE STATES AND SO MILITARY
SPOUSES ARE AGAIN GONNA BE BACK
TO NAVIGATING SORT OF DIFFERENT
APPROACHES. UM YOU KNOW, IN OUR
EXPERIENCE, MILITARY SPOUSES
CARRY MULTIPLE STATE LICENSES,
SO YOU KNOW TO GET, YOU KNOW,
PROOF OF LICENSE AND LICENSURE
IN GOOD STANDING FROM ALL THOSE
STATES TO POTENTIALLY BE
BURDENSOME, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
THE èC E REQUIREMENT. HOW'S
THAT GONNA BE HANDLED OR OR SOME
STATES GONNA LET YOU GO AHEAD
AND PRACTICE OR THEY GONNA MAKE
YOU FULFILL THOSE BEFORE BEFORE
YOU CAN PRACTICE OR OR WORK IN
YOUR PROFESSION? UM, YOU KNOW
THE NOTION AROUND USING YOUR
LICENSE IN THE PREVIOUS TWO
YEARS. UH, YOU KNOW THERE.
THERE'S REALLY NÓ WAY YET ON HOW
TO, AND I THINK STATES ARE GONNA
TAKE IT A DIFFERENT APPROACH ON
HOW TO ADDRESS THAT. UM, AND
THEN YOU KNOW THIS NOTION AROUND
OR SCOPE. UM THAT AGAIN IS GONNA
YOU KNOW, HAVE A DIFFERENT
VARIATIONS IN EVERY STATE. UH,
BUT AGAIN, UH, UNDERSTAND, UH,
CONGRESS WANTED TO TAKE ACTION.
UH, TO TRY TO ALLEVIATE THIS
ISSUE WITH MILI, UH, CONCERNS
MILITARY SPOUSES AND, UH, ISSUES
THAT THEY RUN INTO, BUT AGAIN, I
THINK STATES ARE DOING A GOOD
JOB OF, UM, APPROACHING THAT. UM
SO ALL THESE LEENER COMPACTS
AGAIN, UH, HAVE ROBUST
PROVISIONS AROUND, UH,
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC, SO YOU'RE
REALLY TAKING WHAT THE STATES DO
INDIVIDUALLY AND THEY'RE SHARING
THEIR SOVEREIGNTY OVER THE
BREADTH OF THE COMPACT MEMBER
STATES. UH THERE'S PROVISIONS
AROUND COOPERATING ON
INVESTIGATIONS SHARING
INFORMATION ON INVESTIGATIONS.
UM THROUGH THE COMPACT DATA
SYSTEM, YOU CAN MORE READILY
TRACK. UH, PRACTITIONERS IF YOU
NEED TO. YOU CAN INFORM MEMBER
STATES ABOUT PRACTITIONERS. UM
THAT MAY BE UNDER INVESTIGATION
OR HAD A CASE ADJUDICATED
AGAINST THEM. SO FROM THAT
STANDPOINT, IT REALLY RAISES THE
ABILITY OF BOARDS, UM, TO NOT
ONLY COMMUNICATE, UH, METE OUT
DISCIPLINE IS NOT IMPACTED AT
ALL. UM AND THEY SHARE
INFORMATION AROUND THAT SO THAT
AGAIN, YOU DON'T HAVE ROAD
PRACTITIONERS POTENTIALLY
DRIFTING FROM STATE TO STATE AND
TRYING TO EVADE, UH,
DISCIPLINARY MEASURES. AND
LASTLY, JUST, YOU KNOW, UH, WE
GET THIS QUESTION A LOT LIKE,
WELL, THERE'S 17 LEENER
COMPACTS. I MEAN, WHAT
PROFESSIONS MAYBE AREN'T SUITED
FOR THESE AND WHAT WE SEE AS
BARRIERS IS IF THERE'S NÓ LACK
OF UNIFORMITY UM, IN LICENSURE
REQUIREMENTS FROM STATE TO STATE
THAT THAT MAKES IT VIRTUALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO DO ONE OF THESE
LICENSURE COMPACTS. THERE CAN BE
VARIATIONS. BUT IF THERE'S A
BROAD UH UM UH, DIFFERENCES THAT
BECOMES A PROBLEM. SAME THING
WITH SCOPE, IF SCOPE OF PRACTICE
VARIES WIDELY FROM STATE TO
STATE, UH, PROFESSION IS NOT A
GOOD CANDIDATE THE SIZE OF THE
PROFESSION ALSO, AND THEN THE
ABILITY OF PROFESSION TO, UM,
SUPPORT THE COMPACT FINANCIALLY
AS IT GETS STOOD UP FOR ITS
COMMISSION. SO AGAIN, UM, I'LL
BE AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY AND I'LL TURN IT
BACK OVER TO YOU. GREAT WELL,
FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE WITH US. AND I KNOW
MY COLLEAGUES PROBABLY HAVE SOME
COMMENTS. I ACTUALLY HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS JUST TO KICK
US OFF AND GET US STARTED. IF
YOU DON'T MIND, MR LOGSDON, UH
SO. SO FIRST OF ALL THE FIRST
THING THAT I HEAR YOU SAYING IN
RE IN RELATION TO THE COMPACTS
IS THERE. THERE'S NÓ DOUBT THAT
STATES, INCLUDING CALIFORNIA
WOULD WOULD SEE QUITE A BIT OF
THEIR AUTHORITY BY ENTERING INTO
ONE OF THESE COMPACTS, AND IT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THERE'S A LOT
OF ROOM FOR NEGOTIATION. YOU
SORT OF TAKE IT AS THE LANGUAGE
THAT IS EXISTING. YOU ACCEPT
THAT WHEN YOU ENTER INTO THE
CONTRACT, AS HE MENTIONED, UH,
VERY LEGAL TERM WITHIN THE FOUR
CORNERS OF THE DOCUMENT. AND SO
HOW HAVE OTHER STATES DEALT WITH
COMPACT PROVISIONS THAT ARE
CONTRARY TO STATE PRIORITIES?
CALIFORNIA HAS QUITE A FEW
PRIORITIES THAT MAY NOT LINE UP
WITH OTHER STATES. SO WHAT ARE
THE SUGGESTIONS YOU HAVE FOR
ADDRESSING THOSE KINDS OF
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES? THOSE
PRIORITIES THAT ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA? I'M NOT SURE I
UNDERSTAND THE ROUTE FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE KIND OF CHANGE
CALIFORNIANS SEEK TO CHANGE.
ABSENT BEING A MEMBER OF THE
COMPACT GOVERNANCE TABLE TEAM.
CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT? UM I'LL
TRY TO, UM SO AGAIN, UH, ALL
THESE LICENSE YOUR COMPACTS.
ALLOW THE STATES. TO RETAIN THE
CONTROL OF THE PRACTICE WITHIN
THEIR BORDERS, AND CERTAINLY THE
LICENSURE PROCESS AND
DISCIPLINARY ISSUES. UM
UNDERSTAND THAT STATES HAVE
VARYING REQUIREMENTS AROUND
LEENER, UH, WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN
OTHER STATES. UM IS THAT YOU
KNOW, WHILE YES, THEY'RE
INVESTED IN THESE. THEY BELIEVE
THAT THE BENEFITS OF THE COMPACT
OUTWEIGH YOU KNOW THOSE
POTENTIAL? UH UH UH, ROADBLOCKS,
UH, FOR JOINING. SO UH, YOU KNOW
THE ACCESS TO CARE ISSUES, YOU
KNOW, DIVERSITY OF PRACTITIONERS
FOR THEIR CITIZENS. UM THE
PORTABILITY THE ABILITY OF TO
BRING PRACTITIONER IN BUT ALSO
THE ABILITY OF THEIR
PRACTITIONERS TO PRACTICE IN
OTHER STATES AND MAYBE ENHANCE
THEIR THEIR ECONOMIC PROSPECT.
SO YES, THERE THERE IS THAT
TENSION THERE. BUT YOU KNOW
AGAIN, WE'VE SEEN OVER THREE 100
. SEPARATE PIECES OF LEENER
COMPACT LEGISLATION BE ENACTED
IN THE STATES. UM, WE'VE NOT
SEEN THAT TO BE A, UM UH, A
BARRIER THAT CAN'T BE OVERCOME,
UH, AGAIN BECAUSE OF THE
BENEFITS OF COMPACTS PROVIDE OK,
A COUPLE MORE FOR ME THIS BRIEF
ONES SO YOU KNOW, WE'VE WE'VE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT INTERSTATE
LICENSING COMPACTS, ALLOWING
CERTAIN POPULATIONS TO AS
SOUTHWEST AIRLINES WOULD SAY
MOVE FREELY ABOUT THE COUNTRY,
UH, WITHOUT HAVING TO BE
BURDENED WITH PROFESSIONAL
REGULATION REQUIREMENTS IN EVERY
STATE, WHICH I UNDERSTAND IS THE
OBVIOUS KEY HERE BUT ARE THE
LICENSES INTENDED TO PRACTICE IN
ANOTHER MEMBER STATE TEMPORARY
OR HOW LONG DOES IT MAKE SENSE
FOR SOMEONE TO PRACTICE IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGH A THROUGH A
COMPACT? WELL, UH, IN TERMS OF A
COMPACT PRIVILEGE OR MULTI STATE
LICENSE MEANS THAT THEY'RE, UH,
AUTHORIZED THROUGH THE PENDENCY
OF THE LICENSING PERIOD. SO IF I
HAVE A MULTI STATE LICENSE FROM,
YOU KNOW, HERE IN KENTUCKY, YOU
KNOW IT'S GOOD TILL IT'S
EXPIRATION PERIOD. AND THEN I
WOULD, YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY HAVE
TO RENEW MY LICENSE. UH THEY'RE
NOT IN THE SAME WITH THE COMPACT
PRIVILEGE. IT'S ON THE, UH,
EITHER HOME, STATE LICENSE OR
QUALIFYING. STATE LICENSE. UM
YOU KNOW, YOU COULD PRACTICE
FULL TIME IN ANOTHER COMPACT
MEMBER STATE BASED ON, UH, A
COMPACT. OR A MALTA STATE
LICENSE. UH, THERE'S NOT ANY
SORT OF TEMPORARY PRACTICE
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT, EXCEPT FOR
THE PSYCHOLOGY COMPACT. AGAIN.
IT'S A TELEHEALTH COMPACT, BUT
IT DOES HAVE EMERGENCY
PROVISIONS FOR 30 DAY PRACTICE
IN THE STATE, UH, IN A MEMBER
STATE, IF, UH IF A CLIENT'S IN
CRISIS OR OR OR THEY'RE NEEDED
TO CONSULT IT JUST EXPANDING ON
THAT A LITTLE BIT. YOU YOU
MENTIONED THESE WORKING A LITTLE
BIT LIKE A DRIVERS LICENSE,
WHICH IN CALIFORNIA. WE HANDLE
QUITE DIFFERENTLY THAN THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY. SO ULTIMATELY
SOMEONE WHO LIVES IN CALIFORNIA
GETS THEIR LICENSE HERE AND IS
SUBJECT TO WHATEVER RULES AND
STANDARDS WE'VE PUT IN PLACE.
WHY WOULD WHY WOULD PEOPLE BE
ALLOWED TO BE HERE? IDENTIFY AND
INDEFINITELY? UM, ON THIS
PATHWAY? AND HOW DOES THAT
PROCESS THE COMPACT SUPPORT THE
EXISTING LICENSES THAT WE HAVE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA? YEAH UM, WE
USE THE DRIVER'S LICENSE EXAMPLE
ON A HIGH LEVEL IT NOT MEANT TO
BE, UH, DID MEAN FOR IT TO BE SO
LITERAL. BUT, UM IF, UM SO, FOR
INSTANCE, UH, YOU KNOW, IF I
RESIDE IN KENTUCKY, AND I'M
PRACTICING IN CALIFORNIA, UM YOU
KNOW IF. I HAVE TO. UM I CAN'T
ESTABLISH RESIDENCY THERE. YOU
KNOW, I CAN'T ESSENTIALLY MOVE
TO CALIFORNIA AND THEN PRACTICE
ON THE LICENSE THAT I HAVE IN
KENTUCKY. ALL THE COMPS HAVE
PROVISIONS THAT YOU KNOW IF YOU
HAVE A CHANGE OF RESIDENCE AT
HOME STATE LICENSES VÀ ON YOUR
PRIMARY STATE OF RESIDENCE. YOU
KNOW, YOU'RE REQUIRED TO CHANGE.
UH, YOUR YOUR STATE OF
RESIDENCE. UH AND THAT'S WHERE
THE MEMBER BOARDS WOULD WORK
TOGETHER TO ENSURE THAT YOU KNOW
WHERE YOU'RE REPORTING THAT YOU
RESIDE. YOU ACTUALLY RESIDE
THERE. UM SO IT'S NOT AN
INSTANCE WHERE YOU KNOW YOU CAN
GET A LICENSE IN ONE SAY THAT'S
MY HOME STATE AND THEN
PRACTICING ANY OTHER STATE. UH,
ACTUALLY LIVE THERE FULL TIME.
THE HOME STATE REQUIREMENT IS
MEANT TO ADDRESS THOSE TYPES OF
ISSUES. MOST OF THE PRACTICE IS
TEMPORARY. BUT AGAIN, THE
COMPACT ISN'T LIMITED TO A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF DAYS IN THE
STATE. OR UH, UM, YOU KNOW,
CERTAIN MONTHS OF THE YEAR OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT IT'S NOT
CURTAILED IN THAT MANNER. OK,
I'D LIKE TO OPEN IT UP TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE WHO HAVE
QUESTIONS, SENATOR ROTH. WELL,
JUST TO TELL JUST TO TAG ON TO
THAT RESIDENCY IS A LEGAL TERM.
AND IT IMPLICATES TAXATION
AUTHORITY AND A WHOLE VARIETY OF
THINGS SO THIS REALLY THESE
COMPACTS REALLY OPERATE TO DEAL
WITH FOLKS WHO MOVE FROM STATE
TO STATE ON A SORT OF A
TEMPORARY BASIS IN PERFORMED
SERVICES. IS THAT NOT CORRECT,
MR YES, THAT'S CORRECT. OK? UM.
MADAM CHAIR. DO I HAVE TIME TO
ASK A FEW MORE? I'LL LET OTHER
PEOPLE GO AHEAD. YOU KNOW, I. I
LOOKED AT THE WE WERE PROVIDED
WITH A MODEL AGREEMENT. ONE OF
YOUR MODEL AGREEMENTS AND THE
ONE THING THAT I WAS IMMEDIATELY
TAKEN BY AS THE PHRASE ON THE
COVER NÓ SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES
SHOULD BE MADE TO THE MODEL
LANGUAGE. AND OF COURSE, THERE'S
ANOTHER PROVISION THAT REQUIRES,
AS YOU REFERENCE, THE THAT THE
COMPACT BE ADOPTED BY A STATE
LEGISLATURE IN TOTAL ALL OF THE
TERMS UH, PRESUMABLY WITHOUT A
LOT OF LEGAL REVIEW, AND
CERTAINLY WITHOUT ANY
OPPORTUNITY TO NEGOTIATE, SO
INITIAL QUESTION IS CONCEPTUALLY
. WHY WAS A DECISION MADE TO
REQUIRE THE ADOPTION OF THESE
ACTUAL COMPACTS BY THE STATE
LEGISLATURE, AS OPPOSED TO
ALLOWING THE STATE LEGISLATURE
TO AUTHORIZE ADMINISTRATIONS OR
AGENCIES TO ENTER INTO AND
NEGOTIATE COMPACTS WITH THE
ENTITIES THAT ARE PROPOSING
THEM? UM SO. IT'S SORT OF A TAKE
IT OR LEAVE IT PROPOSITION AS I
TAKE IT. UH, YES, UM THESE ARE
CONTRACTS. UH AND EACH STATE HAS
TO AGREE IN THE SAME WAY THAT UH
UH INDIVIDUALS ENTERING INTO
CONTRACTS OR BUSINESS IN IN INTO
CONTRACTS. THE TERMS HAVE TO BE
THE SAME, UH, 11 STATE CAN HAVE
A DIFFERENT TERM UH, UH THAN
THAN THE OTHER STATE, AND THAT'S
JUST THE NATURE OF THESE
AGREEMENTS. SO, UM, WE WOULD
NEVER I. I KNOW. WE SAY NÓ
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES ON THE COVER
, BUT WE ENCOURAGE STATES TO AND
THEY DO, UM, DO LEGAL REVIEW.
ASK US QUESTIONS. TALK WITH US.
WE'RE WE'RE ARE THIS ARE A, UH,
EXPECTATION ISN'T THAT STATES
ARE GONNA COPY AND PASTE THE
LANGUAGE INTO A BILL AND MOVE
ON. I MEAN, WE YOU KNOW, WE ARE.
WE ARE THERE TO HAVE THOSE TYPES
OF CONVERSATIONS. IN FACT, YOU
KNOW, UH, THERE'S LANGUAGE IN
THE COMPACT. UM, YOU KNOW THAT.
MHM. SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE WE
ALWAYS INCLUDE IN THE COMPACT
AND THESE ARE VERY POWERFUL
TOOLS. UM THEY DO SUPERSEDE
CONFLICTING STATE LAW. NOW YOU
KNOW, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSES ARE HERE
AND PROMOTING PUBLIC PORTABILITY
, SO THAT'S A VERY, VERY AWARE
THAT THAT CAN HAPPEN. BUT STILL,
WE WANT TO BE UPFRONT WITH
STATES ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT
THEY'RE GETTING INTO. UM I THINK
THAT IT'S REALLY JUST SORT OF A
TIME AND EXPENSE ISSUE. UH YOU
KNOW, WE DON'T WE INCLUDE
STATES. THAT'S WHY, UM, YOU
KNOW, THE AMERICAN COUNCIL
ASSOCIATION OR THE FEDERATION OF
STATE. MEDICAL BOARDS. UM WORK
WITH US IS BECAUSE WE PULL IN
STATE OFFICIALS. THESE THINGS
AREN'T WRITTEN IN A BACK ROOM
SOMEWHERE, UH, WITH A MEMBERSHIP
ASSOCIATION OR BOARD FEDERATION,
AND THEN WE TAKE IT OUT TO THE
STATES. UM WE HAVE A ROBUST, UH,
STAKEHOLDER REVIEW PROCESS.
THAT'S UH, MONTHS LONG, UH, TO
GET THAT FEEDBACK. UH YOU KNOW,
THAT'S EXPECTED BECAUSE, LIKE
YOU SAID, ONCE YOU GET TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PART, THEY CAN'T BE
CHANGED SUBSTITUTE WELL, THEN
THAT IS THAT LEADS TO A
COMPANION QUESTION. WHEN I
LOOKED AT THE MODEL AGREEMENT, I
THINK IT'S ON PAGE 23 OF THIS
PARTICULAR ONE IN THE SECTION
CALLED WITHDRAWAL. I NOTE THAT
IN ORDER TO WITHDRAW FROM A
COMPACT ONCE IT'S BEEN ADOPTED.
UM THE STATE LEGISLATURE OF A
MEMBER STATE. MUST INTRODUCE AND
PASS A BILL. IN ORDER TO
WITHDRAW FROM THE COMPACT. NOW
THOSE OF US IN THIS PROCESS KNOW
HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO PUT A
BILL FORWARD TO GET IT THROUGH
COMMITTEES AND GET IT PASSED IN
BOTH HOUSES AND GET IT TO THE
GOVERNOR AND HOPEFULLY GET IT
SIGNED. I'M JUST WONDERING WHAT
THE RATIONALE WAS FOR ON THE
BACK END REQUIRING THE
LEGISLATURE TO, UM POSE AND
PASS. A BILL. IN ORDER TO
WITHDRAW FROM THE COMPACT AS
OPPOSED TO AUTHORIZING
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTION AT THAT
POINT YES, SENATOR. UM, UH.
THAT'S THE UNIQUE NATURE OF
INTERSTATE COMPACTS. UH, I'M NOT
AN ATTORNEY. UH, I. I CAN GET
YOU A MEMO. IF YOU WANT MORE
DETAILED EXAM, UH, EXPLANATION
OF THAT, BUT YOU HAVE TO
WITHDRAW FROM A COMPACT IN THE
SAME WAY MANNER THAT YOU HAVE TO
ENTER A COMPACT AND THE REASON
FOR THAT IS AGAIN. THESE ARE
CONTRACTS. UM THEY'RE BINDING
UPON THE MEMBER STATES. AND SO
YES, THOSE WITHDRAWAL PROVISIONS
. UM UH, ARE, UH, SOMETHING THAT
, UH IT'S NOT, YOU KNOW,
LANGUAGE THAT WE PREFER THE, UH,
GROUPS THAT WE'RE WORKING WITH
PREFER AND WANT TO PUT IT IN
THERE. IN AN EFFORT TO, UH
FORESTALL PEOPLE FROM EVEN, UH,
GROUPS OR STATES FROM, UH, EVEN
THINKING ABOUT WITHDRAWING.
THEY'LL SPEAK TO THE UNIQUE
NATURE OF THESE CONSTITUTIONAL
MAKINGS. NOW, IN TERMS OF THE
WHY FOR THE COMPACT, YOU KNOW,
WE'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME IN
THIS COMMITTEE. AND MY
COLLEAGUES, PARTICULARLY TALKING
ABOUT OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING AS
A BARRIER TO EMPLOYMENT, SO
WE'RE WELL AWARE OF THAT. AND OF
COURSE, CALIFORNIA WE'VE SEEN
THE LICENSE. EVERYTHING UM, BUT
WE HAVE OVER TIME, UM, BEEN
TALKING ABOUT LICENSED
PORTABILITY, AND I RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE ARE VARIOUS WAYS TO
GET THERE A LICENSE BY
ENDORSEMENT RECIPROCITY, WHICH
IN THE LAW BUSINESS WE SOMETIMES
SEE, BUT NOT OUT HERE. UH,
EXPEDITED AND TEMPORARY. SURE.
AND OF COURSE, THESE INTERSTATE
COMPACTS. WE HERE SEEM TO HAVE
BEEN MOVING AT LEAST IN THE PAST
FEW YEARS TOWARD TEMPORARY AND
EXPEDITED LICENSURE. WHETHER
IT'S FOR NURSES OR TEACHERS OR
OR OTHERS. AND SO SINCE WE HAVE
THIS EXPEDITED AND TEMPORARY
LICENSURE MOVEMENT HERE TO TRY
TO ENCOURAGE FOLKS WHO MOVE HERE
TO GET BECOME LICENSED QUICKLY
AND GET TO WORK, AND GIVEN THE
FACT THAT THE CONGRESS ON THE
FEDERAL SIDE HAS AND I'VE READ
THE LAW. I THINK I DISAGREE A
LITTLE BIT WITH YOU, BUT PRETTY
MUCH ELIMINATED IF NOT TOTALLY
ELIMINATED THE ISSUE WITH
MILITARY SPOUSE SPOUSES BY THIS
AMENDMENT AMENDMENT TO THE, UH,
SERVICE MEMBERS CIVIL RELIEF
ACT. UM WHAT IS THE RATIONALE
FOR THE ADOPTION OF A COMPACT IN
CALIFORNIA? IF WE'RE IF WHETHER
IT'S COSMETOLOGIST OR SOMEBODY
ELSE IF WE CAN LICENSE THEM IN 2
TO 3 DAYS OR EVEN A WEEK, AND IF
THE LICENSE FEE IS $50 OR $100
OR $200, SO IT'S QUICK AND IT'S
FAIRLY INEXPENSIVE. WHAT WHAT IS
THE RATIONALE AT THIS POINT? NOT
10 YEARS AGO, BUT AT THIS POINT
FOR CALIFORNIA TO CONSIDER THE
ADOPTION OF A COMPACT, FOR
EXAMPLE. YEAH. UH, SENATOR, I
THINK, UM. I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH
CALIFORNIA'S RECIPROCITY, UH,
STATUTES OR OR LICENSE BY
ENDORSEMENT. UH BUT WHAT WE'VE
SEEN IN OTHER STATES IS, YOU
KNOW YES, YOU KNOW, ONCE.
PRACTITIONER PROVIDES EVERYTHING
THAT THE BOARD NEEDS. IT MOVES
QUICKLY, BUT BUT THEY SPEND
WEEKS IF NOT MONTHS, PULLING
THAT INFORMATION TOGETHER. SO I
DON'T WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN OTHER
STATES IS IT'S NOT FASTER OR, UH
AND IT'S NOT A LOT OF TIMES A
SPEEDY PROCESS. UM AND THEN I
THINK THERE'S A TWO WAY NATURE
OF A COMPACT WITH WITH A
COMPACT. NOT ONLY IS CALIFORNIA
ABLE TO, YOU KNOW, PULL, UH,
PRACTITIONERS IN, UH, BUT, YOU
KNOW, CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PRACTICE IN OTHER
STATES IF THEY DESIRE SO YOU
KNOW, THEY'RE ABLE TO, YOU KNOW,
GROW THEIR ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE SAME WAY
THAT OTHER STATES WE RUN INTO
THIS WITH ULR LAWS. UH YOU KNOW,
WE HAD STATES SAY TO US AND WHEN
WE'RE HERE TO PRO TO, UH, TALK
ABOUT THE BENEFITS OF COMPAQ.
CERTAINLY THE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR INTERSTATE COMPACTS BELIEVE
IN COMPACTS. BUT YOU KNOW, AS
OUR èC E Ó SAYS OUR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR, WE DON'T TELL STATES
WHAT TO DO. BUT WE BELIEVE IN
THESE MECHANISMS. UM YOU KNOW,
WE'VE PASSED THE ULR LAW. YOU
KNOW, WE'VE SOLVED THIS ISSUE.
YOU'VE CERTAINLY, UH, AIDED
PORTABILITY. YOU'VE ENHANCED
PORTABILITY, BUT, UH, YOU KNOW
YOUR CITIZENS DON'T RECEIVE
THOSE SAME BENEFITS BECAUSE WE
DON'T SEE THOSE PROVISIONS OUT
IN IN OTHER STATES, AND IF THEY
ARE, THEY ALL WORK DIFFERENTLY.
THEY ALL HAVE DIFFERENT
REQUIREMENTS. TYPICALLY AND SO
YOU KNOW THAT TWO WAY NATURE,
UH, OF A COMPACT, I THINK IS
IMPORTANT. UH, AS WELL AND THEN,
UH, YOU KNOW, UM II? I DON'T
WANNA YOU KNOW, UH, I JUST
DISAGREE ABOUT THAT FEDERAL LAW.
I THINK FROM A PRACTICAL
STANDPOINT, ULTIMATELY, IT'S NOT
GONNA BENEFIT. UM MILITARY
SPOUSES. I HOPE I'M WRONG. UM
BUT, YOU KNOW, IN IN OUR
CORRESPONDENCE WITH, UH, YOU
KNOW, SENATOR LEE OF UTAH WHEN,
WHEN HE TRIED TO INSERT THIS
INTO THE NATIONAL DEFENSE
AUTHORIZATION ACT A COUPLE OF
TIMES. IT'S LIKE YOU KNOW IT. IT
WAS ALMOST AS IF THEY DIDN'T
HAVE ANY IDEA THAT STATES WERE
WERE DOING THIS WORK THAT STATES
WERE TRYING TO HELP MILITARY
SPOUSES AND THAT YOU KNOW THIS
SORT OF OVERARCHING FEDERAL
SOLUTION. UM YOU KNOW, FROM A
PRACTICAL STANDPOINT, IT'S VERY
PROBLEMATIC. I THINK FOR BOARDS
TO IMPLEMENT MAY MAYBE NOT IN
CALIFORNIA, BUT I THINK OTHER
STATES ARE GOING TO STRUGGLE. MY
WELL, I'M MADAM CHAIR. MAY I
CONTINUE? GO AHEAD. GENERAL NÓ
NÓ NÓ II. I JUST PULLED THE LAW
AND IT SAYS IN ANY CASE, IN
WHICH A SERVICE MEMBER OR SPOUSE
OF A SERVICE MEMBER HAS A
COVERED LICENSE. AND THEY
RELOCATE RESIDENCY BECAUSE THE
MILI I'M PARAPHRASING MILITARY
ORDERS FOR MILITARY SERVICE.
OUTSIDE OF THE JURISDICTION
WHERE THE LICENSE IS ISSUED. THE
COVERED LICENSE SHALL BE
CONSIDERED VALID AT A SIMILAR
SCOPE OF PRACTICE AND IN THE
DISCIPLINE APPLIED FOR SO IN
OTHER WORDS, IF THEY MOVE, AND
THEY'RE LICENSED IN ONE STATE,
THEY'RE LICENSED IN THAT STATE'S
GOOD IN THE NEXT STATE. NOW
THERE ARE SOME CONDITIONS.
OBVIOUSLY IT HAS TO BE IN GOOD
STANDING. AND THIS AND THAT NOW,
IN FAIRNESS TO THOSE OF YOU WHO
DO COMPAQS IT DOES SAY THAT IF
THE SERVICE MEMBER IS IN A
LICENSED IN A STATE THAT HAS AN
INTERSTATE LICENSE COMPACT, OF
COURSE. THIS PARTICULAR
AMENDMENT TO THE SERVICE MEMBERS
. CIVIL RELIEF ACT DOESN'T APPLY
. SO IF YOU'RE IN A COMPACT
STATE, YOU CAN MOVE FROM COMPACT
TO COMPACT STATE AND NOT BE
COVERED. BUT IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT'S PRETTY DEFINITIVE. I
DON'T KNOW. DO MAY I ASK A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
COMPACT MANURE? I'M WILLING TO
DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUES? I GOT A
QUESTION. HOW DO YOU WANT ME TO
LET A COUPLE OTHER? YES I
CERTAINLY DO. COME BACK TO YOU.
BUT PLEASE DO KEEP YOUR
QUESTIONS BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT LINE. UH
SENATOR ARCHULETA AND THEN
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. UH,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INFORMATION
AND PIGGYBACKING ON WHAT THE
GENERAL IS TALKING ABOUT, YOU
KNOW, LET'S LET'S WALK ME
THROUGH THIS BECAUSE IT SOUNDED
LIKE YOU. YOU WERE NOT IN
AGREEMENT. OBVIOUSLY WITH THE
FEDERAL SIDE. I'M EXCITED
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT YOU
TAKE A MILITARY PERSONNEL FORT
BRAGG, NORTH CAROLINA, AND, UH
HE GETS SHIPPED OVER HERE. LOCK,
STOCK AND BARREL TO CALIFORNIA
AND HIS SPOUSE OR HER SPOUSE. UH
IT WILL ONLY BE HERE FOR A YEAR,
MAYBE THREE TOPS BECAUSE THAT'S
THE DURATION OF A MOVEMENT. UH
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE TIME FOR
THE FAMILY TO START MAKING SOME
MONEY AND SURVIVING WHEN THEY
GET TO AAA TO THE HIGHER COST OF
LIVING HERE IN CALIFORNIA, AND
IT'S IMPERATIVE WE GET THEM
WORKING QUICKLY. BUT WHAT? WHAT
UH, ROADBLOCKS DO YOU SEE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WHEN THAT MOVEMENT
IS MADE? AND WHEN YOU KIND OF
DISAGREE WITH THE FEDERAL
MOVEMENT, WHAT WHAT DO YOU SEE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THAT WOULD
HINDER A SMOOTH TRANSITION INTO
THE EMPLOYMENT SIDE CYCLE WITH
SOME OF THESE PROFESSIONALS.
YES, WELL AGAIN. I'M NOT, UH,
FAMILIAR WITH HOW CALIFORNIA IS
GOING TO IMPLEMENT THIS OR HAS
IMPLEMENTED THIS. WHAT WHAT I WE
DO SEE IN OTHER STATES IS THERE
AND I THINK JUST GENERALLY, UH,
WITH SOME OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
MENTIONED, UM, YOU KNOW THE
PROVISIONS THAT THAT THE SPOUSE
HAS TO PROVIDE, SO I, YOU KNOW,
I HAVE TO GIVE YOU THE LETTER.
MILITARY SPOUSES ARE TYPICALLY
LICENSED IN MULTIPLE STATES. SO
FROM EACH OF THOSE STATES
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO GET, UH, A
LETTER SAYING THAT, YOU KNOW,
NOT. THEY'RE IN GOOD STAND.
THEY'RE IN GOOD STANDING. UH
AND, UM YOU KNOW, THE HOW TO
PROVE THAT YOU'VE BEEN
PRACTICING IN THE PREVIOUS TWO
YEARS AGAIN. YOU KNOW,
CALIFORNIA MAY HAVE A VERY, UH,
EXPEDITED WAY A VERY GOOD WAY OF
DOING THAT, UH, I DON'T EXPECT
EVERY STATE TO SO THEY'RE GONNA
RUN INTO THAT CHALLENGE. LIKE
WELL, IT WAS DIFFERENT
CALIFORNIA THAN THAN THAN IT IS
HERE. THE REQUIREMENT TO
COMPLETE THE CONTINUING ED IN
THE STATE WHERE YOU'RE MOVING.
DO I HAVE TO DO THAT BEFORE? DO
I HAVE TO DO IT AFTER? UM AND
THAT'S IN ADDITION TO THE
MULTIPLE LICENSES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY HOLD BECAUSE AGAIN,
YOU KNOW, GETTING AN
OCCUPATIONAL AND, UM, IT IS.
IT'S UH, YOU KNOW IT GETS
PLAYED. YOU KNOW, ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE. IT'S NOT, BUT YOU
KNOW, ONCE YOU HAVE IT, YOU
DON'T WANT TO RELINQUISH IT. SO
YOU KNOW, WE SEE MILITARY
SPOUSES THAT CARRY LICENSE. YOU
KNOW, 8 TO 10 LICENSES, AND NOW
THEY'VE GOT ANOTHER CONTINUING
EDUCATION. UH, REQUIREMENT ON
TOP OF THAT. SO, UH AGAIN. I
JUST I DON'T THINK THAT THAT
IT'S GONNA SOLVE THE PROBLEMS IN
THE WAY THAT THAT, UM THAT IT'S
LAID OUT. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR IN A REALLY
APPRECIATING THE DISCUSSION. UM
I GUESS. AM ALWAYS REMINDED WHEN
OUR GOVERNOR SAYS THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS NÓ PEERS AND, UM
SO THIS THIS THIS CONVERSATION
IS AN INTERESTING ONE. GIVEN THE
SCALE, UM OF OUR ECONOMY, AND
THE, UM EDUCATION AND SKILL SET
OF OUR AMAZING AND PRODUCTIVITY
OF OUR OUR AMAZING CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE. AND I THINK THIS
COMMITTEE HAS DONE. UH, A LOT TO
ENSURE, UM, THAT WE ARE DOING
ALL THAT WE CAN TO EXPEDITE. THE
LICENSURE PROCESS AND
PARTICULARLY FOCUSING ON THOSE
INDUSTRIES WHERE WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT VACANCIES. UM, I
GUESS YOU KNOW. YOU'RE IN
KENTUCKY. UM SO I'M TRYING TO
ALSO THINK ABOUT THESE OTHER
STATES AND HOW YOU TALKED ABOUT,
YOU KNOW HOW WORKERS FROM
KENTUCKY COMING LIVING IN
KENTUCKY AND COMING INTO
CALIFORNIA TO WORK IN TAKING
RESOURCES BACK TO KENTUCKY? UM
I'M CURIOUS. YOU KNOW? HOW DOES
THE UM. HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIANS? UM PARTICULARLY
THOSE THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF BEING LICENSED WHO'VE
GONE THROUGH THE REQUIREMENTS?
UM THAT, UH, THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA. UM WANT TO SEE PUT
FORTH HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT OUR
WORKERS ARE NOT PUSHED OUT BY
THESE OUT OF STATE WORKERS WHO
ARE COMING IN? UM FROM PLACES
LIKE KENTUCKY, UM THROUGH THIS
INTERSTATE COMPACT, AND I'M
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED ABOUT
SOME OF THE LOWER AND MODERATE
WAGED OCCUPATIONS. IT SEEMS LIKE
YOU TRACK ON THESE TRENDS. I'M
CURIOUS WHAT WHAT THAT'S SHOWING
IN TERMS OF THE IMPACT OF
EXISTING WORKFORCE WHO HAVE GONE
THROUGH ALL OF THE NECESSARY
STEPS HERE IN THE STATE TO DO
SIMILAR WORK. UH, YEAH. THANK
YOU, UM THE ONLY, UH, STUDY THAT
WE HAVE IS FROM THE INTERSTATE
MEDICAL LICENSE OR COMPACT, AND
WE CAN CERTAINLY SHARE THAT WITH
THE, UH, COMMITTEE. ANECDOTALLY
WE DON'T SEE THAT, UH IN OTHER
STATES WITH OTHER PROFESSIONS,
WHAT WE SEE IS MORE OF A SUPPLY
SIDE IMPACT. UH, THE MORE
COUNSELORS THE MORE SOCIAL
WORKERS. THE MORE PSYCHOLOGISTS,
UH, THE MORE OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPISTS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
MORE OF THOSE SERVICES ARE TAKEN
UP. UM YOU KNOW, I DON'T THINK
UH, ANY STATE, UH, CAN MEET THE
NEEDS OF EVERY PATIENT, UH, FOR
MENTAL HEALTH CARE AND THE
ABILITY OF THESE PRACTITIONERS
TO SPREAD THEIR REACH. UM UH,
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S GONNA GOING TO
DRIVE RESIDENTS OUT OF THE
MARKETPLACE. IT'S ACTUALLY, UM,
GOING TO CREATE GREATER
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO GET
CARE. UM BUT AGAIN WHAT WE CAN
SHARE. THE, UH, THESE THINGS ARE
ARE RELATIVELY NEW. UH BUT MORE
DATA IS BECOMING AVAILABLE EVERY
YEAR, AND LIKE I SAID, I THINK
IT WAS A SAN JOSE STATE THAT DID
A STUDY. UH FOR THE INTERSTATE
MEDICAL LICENSE. UH, COMPACT. WE
CAN WE CAN GET THAT WITH YOU,
UH, TO YOU AND SHARE IT WITH ME.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE THAT AND
PARTICULARLY WHAT THE IMPACT IS
IN TERMS OF, YOU KNOW, FISCAL
IMPACT TO THE STATE. UM YOU KNOW
, AS YOU KNOW, WORKERS WHO LIVE
AND BUY PROPERTY. UM UM, PAY
SALES TAX. YOU KNOW, THERE'S
SORT OF A THERE'S A RIPPLE
EFFECT. UM IN TERMS OF AN
ECONOMY WHERE, UH, WORKERS ARE.
BEING TRAINED, UM, CERTIFIED,
LICENSED AND THEN WORKING IN
THAT STATE. I'M I'M ALSO CURIOUS
. JUST LIKE WHAT THE WHAT THE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS ARE WHEN THE
WORKFORCE DOESN'T YOU KNOW?
OBVIOUSLY DOES THE WORK PROVIDE
THE SERVICE BUT THEN TAKES THOSE
RESOURCES BACK TO THEIR HOME
STATE FROM FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, SO I'D BE CURIOUS TO
KNOW MORE ABOUT THAT. UM, IF
THERE IS SOME SOME SOME DATA ON
THAT MY OTHER QUESTION THAT I
HAD, AND I THINK YOU MENTIONED
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE REGISTERED.
UM UH REGISTERED NURSES AND THE
COST OF THESE COMPACTS. UM. UH,
DIFFERENT BOARDS AND
ASSOCIATIONS. YOU MENTIONED THAT
THERE WAS SOME NEGATIVE IMPACT.
UM COULD COULD YOU EXPAND ON
THAT AND SAY A LITTLE MORE? UM
WELL, UM. WHAT WE'RE SEEING
RIGHT NOW. UM, IS THAT THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR, UM. STANDING
UP IN INTERSTATE COMMISSION.
ISN'T BEING BORN BY THE STATES.
UM UM, IT'S BEING BORN BY THE,
UM ORGANIZATIONS THAT THAT, UH,
SPEARHEADED THE EFFORT TO, UH,
CREATE THE COMPACT. SO, UM, UH
THERE'S ONLY TWO COMPACTS THAT
CURRENTLY ASSESS THEIR MEMBER
STATES. THE NURSING COMPACT, I
THINK ASSESSES MEMBER STATES
6000 A YEAR. SIDE PACK HAS A
SLIDING SCALE BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF PRIVILEGES. UH, THEY
ISSUE PER STATE. UH, THAT'S NOT
TO SAY. THEY WANT. THEY WON'T
EVER START ASSESSING STATES AND
I THINK THAT IF STATES ARE
SEEING BENEFITS FROM THESE
COMPACTS, AND I BELIEVE THEY
WILL, UH, I BELIEVE THEY'D BE
INTERESTED IN IN SUPPORTING THE
COMPACTS IN SOME WAY. BUT RIGHT
NOW, UM, WHAT YOU'RE SEEING IS A
COALITION OF GROUPS IN THE
PROFESSION THAT PRUDENTIALLY
ORGANIZATION, A MEMBERSHIP
ASSOCIATION, A BOARD ASSOCIATION
COMING TOGETHER AND HELPING FUND
THE OPER OPERATIONS. SO YOU KNOW
THAT BURDEN ISN'T FALLING ON THE
STATES AND AGAIN. I WANT TO BE
CLEAR. I'M NOT SAYING IT NEVER
WILL, UH, BUT CURRENTLY THAT'S
NOT HAPPENING. BOARDS IN MEMBER
STATES. UM YOU KNOW, I'M NOT
GONNA ALSO SAY THAT THEY'RE NOT
GONNA HAVE ANY COST. UH, YOU
KNOW, UH, INTERFACING WITH THE
DATA SYSTEM OR PROVIDING THAT
DATA, UH, IN MOST STATES,
THERE'S NÓ PHYSICAL NOTES IN
SOME STATES. THERE THERE ARE, UM
, BUT, YOU KNOW, WE ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THERE MAY BE AAA COST TO
THAT. UM BUT WHAT WE'VE ALSO
SEEN AGAIN, ANECDOTALLY, UM, IS
THAT YOU KNOW, UH, NOT
PROCESSING LICENSES FREES UP
STAFF, UH, TO DO MORE SORT OF
PUBLIC. TYPE OF ACTIVITIES OR
MORE ACTIVITIES. UH AROUND, UH,
WHAT THE BOARD'S TRUE MISSION IS
WHICH IS TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
SO UM, UH, YOU KNOW, FROM A
FINANCIAL STANDPOINT, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S THAT'S UM, WHAT I'VE GOT,
UH, THEY ALL ALL THE LICENSE
YOUR COMPACTS AGAIN. THAT ARE
OPERATING SEEK TO KEEP FEES. UH,
AS LOW AS POSSIBLE, BUT A AGAIN
YOU KNOW, THEY HAVE TO GO AWAY
INTO FUNDING THEIR OPERATIONS.
UM P Tð, FOR EXAMPLE ESTATES TO
KEEP THE FEE AT $45. SOME DO
SOME DON'T SOME DON'T CHARGE
ANYTHING. UM, UH, BUT, UH, YOU
KNOW, THE BENEFITS OF THIS, I
THINK, UH, THAT PRACTITIONERS
ARE SEEING YOU KNOW, THEY'RE
THEY'RE THEY'RE WILLING TO PAY
THAT THAT THAT FEE IN ORDER TO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO HAVE MULTI
STATE PRACTICE, UH, IN A MANNER
THAT COMPACT PROVIDES. YOUR
RESPONSE BROUGHT ONE OF THE
QUESTION TO MIND. SO YOU'RE
SAYING THE OVERSIGHT AND
MONITORING AND ENFORCEMENT OF
LET'S SAY THE MALPRACTICE OF
INDIVIDUALS ON, UM. AN
INTERSTATE COMPACT THAT THE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY FALLS ON THE
STATE. OR DOES THAT
RESPONSIBILITY? SHOULD THERE BE
ANY SORT OF UM NEGLIGENCE OR
QUESTION OF THAT INDIVIDUAL'S
LICENSING AND, UM. UM THE TYPE
OF CARE OR SERVICE THAT THEY'RE
PROVIDING. DOES THE COMPACT
ENSURE THE SAFETY OF THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT'S WORKING IN A
STATE OR IS THAT ON THE STATE?
SO TO COVER THOSE COSTS. AS
WELL. I'M NOT, UM. SO IF I'M A
PRACTITIONER, REGARDLESS OF THE
STATE, I AM I MEAN, I'M
RESPONSIBLE FOR MY MALPRACTICE
INSURANCE OR MY LIABILITY
INSURANCE. I MEAN IT. IT REALLY
IS AKIN TO THE LEENER PROCESS.
IF I'M WORKING IN CALIFORNIA,
I'M UNDER THE JURISDICTION OF
CALIFORNIA. UH I HAVE TO ABIDE
BY CALIFORNIA SCOPE. UH, I'M I'M
SUBJECT TO, YOU KNOW, TO THEIR
DISCIPLINARY WORKS. UM SO FROM
THAT STANDPOINT, YOU KNOW,
CALIFORNIA DOES HAVE CONTROL. UM
BUT AS FAR AS, UH, THE COST FOR
LIKE MALPRACTICE OR LIABILITY
INSURANCE. THAT WOULD BE, UH, ON
THE PRACTITIONER. UM SO THAT
AGAIN. THAT'S THE SAME THING
THAT YOU GET WITH THAT. THAT'S
THE SAME, UH, PROCESS YOU HAVE
WITH THE LICENSE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. SMALL
CREVIS. I'M JUST GONNA MAKE ONE
COMMENT LESS OF A QUESTION. AND
THEN I'M IN THAT HAND IT BACK TO
SENATOR ROTH TO, UH, FINISH US
OUT WITH THIS PANEL, BUT I. I
THINK THAT, UH, SENATOR. 40
MILLION PERSON QUESTION. BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT WE COLLECTIVELY
REPRESENT. IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE
THERE ARE A LOT OF COMPREHENSIVE
STUDIES. TO ADDRESS THE QUESTION
THAT SHE ASKED, AND YOU KNOW,
LEGAL REVIEW AND QUESTIONS,
WHICH ARE ENCOURAGED UPON
ENTERING INTO THE COMPACT IS
VERY DIFFERENT THAN BEING ABLE
TO EFFECTUATE OR CHANGED THE
TERMS. THOSE ARE VERY DIFFERENT
LEGAL PROCESSES AND CALIFORNIA
HAS. STRONG PROCEDURES IN PLACE,
AND THAT MAY BE THE
UNDERSTATEMENT OF A LIFETIME.
THAT ARE INTENDED TO IMPACT
OUTCOMES. WE START WITH AN
OUTCOME IN MIND, FOR EXAMPLE,
DIVERSITY OR EQUITY OR WORKING
CONDITIONS. AND THEN WE SET
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES IN PLACE
TO TRY TO EFFECTUATE THOSE
OUTCOMES. I WORRY ABOUT A
COMPACT WITH OTHER STATES THAT
AS SENATOR SMALL CUEVAS HAS VERY
ELOQUENTLY ALREADY STATED,
POTENTIALLY DON'T HOLD THE SAME
VALUE SET AS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, AS OUR GOVERNOR
SAYS, HAS NO PEERS, RIGHT? HOW
WE ENTER INTO A COMPACT BEYOND A
TEMPORARY PEACE, WHICH HAS
SENATOR ARCHULETTA STATED IS
COULD BE REALLY HELPFUL FOR THE
STATED GROUP OF MILITARY
SPOUSES. HOWEVER I THINK YOU'LL
HEAR HERE IN A MOMENT FROM
SENATOR ROTH. IT'S NOT REALLY
NECESSARY FOR THIS COMPACT IN
ORDER FOR THOSE MILITARY SPOUSES
UNDER THE NEW FEDERAL LAW. TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THOSE SAME OUTCOMES
. SO THAT'S MY CONCERN, AND I
JUST ADDED ON TOP HERE IN HAND
THIS BACK TO SENATOR ROTH TO
FINISH US OUT WITH THIS PANEL.
WELL CARE, DAD INDULGE YOU TO
RESPOND TO SOME OF THAT. SURE,
YOU CAN. UM I HEAR I HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING, UM, AND WHEN NOT
TRYING TO DISPUTE THAT I DON'T
THINK I'M. COMPACTS MERELY A
MEANS TO GET ACCESS TO A STATE.
YOU KNOW, THE WAY CALIFORNIA
REGULATES A PROFESSION, YOU KNOW
THE ITS SCOPE OF PRACTICE. UM
IT'S REQUIREMENTS FOR DIFFERENT
TIERS OF THE PROFESSION WOULD
ALL REMAIN IN PLACE. SO YOU
KNOW, CALIFORNIA NOT HAVING
APPEAR WOULD APPLY TO ME AS A
PRACTITIONER COMING INTO
CALIFORNIA. I DON'T I DON'T GET
TO BRING MY PRACTICE ACT FROM
ANOTHER STATE IN THERE. I DON'T
WE'RE NOT CREATING SOME SORT OF
SPECIAL CLASS OF PRACTITIONERS.
THAT GETS THE FONT THE RULES IN
EVERY STATE BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
THEY'RE STATE ALLOWS THIS OR
DOESN'T ALLOW THAT. SO I JUST
WANTED TO BE CLEAR THAT THAT,
UM, YOU KNOW, BY JOINING THE
COMPACT YOU'RE ESSENTIALLY
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO COME IN YOUR
STATE BY THE COMPACT INSTEAD OF
A LIVE SINGER OR SOME OTHER
AGREEMENT. UM YOU'RE NOT
RELINQUISH. SHE CONTROLLED THE
PRACTICE WITHIN YOUR BOARDS. IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE GO A
LOT FARTHER THAN JUST THE ACTUAL
PRACTICE ITSELF. THERE IS A LOT
THAT HAPPENS AROUND RECRUITMENT.
WHAT WE DO WITH OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WHAT WE DO OUT IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS WITH OUR OWN
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PARTNERS,
AND SO I THINK WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO GET YOU TO UNDERSTAND IS THIS
WOULD BE A SHORTCUT TO THAT
STEP, WHICH GIVES US PAUSE AND
CONCERN BECAUSE WE'VE SPENT MANY
YEARS AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
TRYING TO CREATE AVENUES FOR
PEOPLE ACROSS OUR STATE TO FIND
THEIR WAY TO MIDDLE CLASS
EMPLOYMENT THROUGH THE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS THAT WE LICENSE AND
REGULATE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT THAT'S REALLY AT
THE ROOT OF MY QUESTION, SENATOR
RAF OH, THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
I'LL TRY TO MAKE THIS QUICK IN
TERMS OF THESE COMPLEX
GENERALLY, UM I MEAN, THE ONES
I'VE LOOKED AT. I DIDN'T SEE ANY
SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS, FOR
EXAMPLE, FOR CERTAIN EDUCATIONAL
OR PROFESSIONAL, UM,
REQUIREMENTS OR SCHOOL
ACCREDITATIONS OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT IS CAN A MEMBER STATE
SPECIFIES CERTAIN ACCREDITATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR ENTRY INTO THE
STATE TO PRACTICE OR IS THAT
LIMITED BY THE TERMS OF THE
COMPACT AND IF THE COMPACT IS
SILENT SILENCE? YES SENATOR. UM
IF YOU'RE NOT SEEING THOSE IN A
COMPACT, THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE
UNIFORMITY AMONG THE STATES
AROUND THOSE PROVISIONS, SO
THERE WAS NO NEED FOR US TO
INCLUDE SPECIFIC PROVISIONS
AROUND THAT FOR PRACTITIONERS OF
ME, THAT'S THAT'S UNTRUE OF ALL
OF THEM, BUT IN SOME OF THEM,
THERE'S NO NEED TO ESSENTIALLY
RECREATE THE WILL. WE WANT TO
BUILD THESE DOCUMENTS. BROADLY
ENOUGH THAT YOU KNOW THEY CAN
STAY EVERGREEN THROUGH THROUGH
COMMISSION RULES AND NOT BUILD
THEM SO NARROW THAT WITHIN FIVE
YEARS, YOU KNOW, UM THEY'RE
WORTHLESS. YOU CAN'T BUILD THEM
SO BROADLY, THOUGH, THAT YOU
KNOW STATES ARE GOING TO HAVE
DISCOMFORT ABOUT JOINING THEM
BECAUSE OF THE RULES PROCESS. SO
AGAIN, YOU MAY NOT SEE SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS ON THE ON THE
PRACTITIONER SIDE THAT MAYBE ON
WHAT A STATE HAS TO DO TO
QUALIFY TO JOIN. UM BUT AGAIN,
THAT'S VERY LIKELY THE RESULT OF
THE UNIFORMITY FOR THAT
PROFESSION AMONG THE STATES.
GOOD AND THEN I ASSUME THAT A
MEMBER STATE NOT THE HOME STATE,
BUT A MEMBER STATES, SOME STATE
THAT IS TAKING LICENSES IN UNDER
A COMPACT THAT THE MEMBER STATE
CAN CHARGE FEES TO THE LICENSE.
HE COMING INTO THE STATE TO
COVER THE COST OF ENFORCEMENT.
OKAY THAT WOULD NECESSARILY
DEPEND ON THE MODEL. SO IF IT'S
A MULTI STATE LICENSE MODEL, YOU
CAN CERTAINLY CHARGE UM HIGHER
FEE FOR THE MULTI STATE LICENSE
BUT A PRACTITIONER COMING INTO
YOUR STATE ON A MULTI STATE
LICENSE. UM YOU KNOW, YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE A MEANS TO CHARGE
THEM AGAIN. UM THE BOARDS THAT
THAT OPERATE THAT WAY. SAY THAT
IT'S NOT IMPACTING THEM
NEGATIVELY FROM A FINANCIAL
STANDPOINT AND CERTAINLY GET YOU
MORE INFORMATION ON THAT IF
YOU'D LIKE IT, BUT WE'RE WITH
THE COMPAQ PRIVILEGE MODEL. YES
UH, THOSE COMPACTS EMPOWER THE
STATES TO THEY CAN CHARGE A FEE
FOR THAT COMPACT PRIVILEGE. YES
I'M NOT SURE I UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCE SO I HAVE A HOME
STATE. I'VE GOT A WHOEVER YOU
WANT TO CALL IT A LICENSEE FROM
THE STATE OF GEORGIA, AND THAT'S
THE HOME STATE AND THEY'RE
COMING TO CALIFORNIA. MHM AND
THEY'RE GONNA PRACTICE ON THAT.
MULTI AND THEY ARE PART OF THE
MULTI STATE LICENSE PROCESS AND
THEY WANT TO COME INTO
CALIFORNIA AND WORK ON THEIR
MULTI WORK WITH THEIR MULTI
STATE LICENSE HERE. YES I ASSUME
CALIFORNIA HAS THE RIGHT AND IN
SOME CASES, THE OBLIGATION TWO
FROM A PUBLIC SAFETY STANDPOINT
TO ENFORCE PRACTICE RULES IN THE
STATE, RIGHT AND THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA CAN REVOKE THE
MULTI STATE LICENSES PRIVILEGED
TO WORK IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. YES AND ALL THAT
CARRIES A COST, SO CAN
CALIFORNIA ASSESS A FEED TO THE
PERSON COMING INTO CALIFORNIA
UNDER A MULTI STATE COMPACT? TO
COVER THE COSTS OF MONITORING
ENFORCEMENT AND DISCIPLINARY
ACTION INSIDE THE STATE BORDERS.
UM CERTAINLY, IT CAN BE
REIMBURSED FOR THE COST OF AN
INVESTIGATION FROM THE
PRACTITIONER IF THE STATE
CURRENTLY ALLOWS THAT AND MOST
STATES DO, I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE A MECHANISM
HERE. IN CALIFORNIA TO CONDUCT
DISCIPLINARY PROCEEDINGS AND
CONDUCT AND IMPOSED REVOKED
LICENSE REVOCATIONS, AND IT'S A
PROCESS AND UNFORTUNATELY FOR
THOSE WHO ARE LICENSED HERE,
IT'S NOT CHEAP. RIGHT AND IF. IF
YOU CAN RECOVER THOSE COSTS FROM
A PRACTITIONER, YOU CAN RECOVER
THOSE FROM SOMEONE PRACTICING IN
CALIFORNIA UNDER THE COMBAT. BUT
BUT GENERALLY SPEAKING, WE WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO CHARGE THE
LICENSEE DRIVING ACROSS THE
BORDER. THE STATE LINE RATHER,
UM A FEE TO PRACTICE IN THE
STATE UNDER A MULTI LICENSE
COMPACT. NO IF YOU'RE IN THAT
COMPACT, THOUGH, YOU'LL HAVE
PRACTITIONERS PURCHASING OR
GETTING MULTI STATE LICENSES AND
THAT WOULD BE HOW YOU WOULD
RECOVER YOUR COST. NOW EVEN
RECOVERING. YOU TRY TO SPEED IT
UP. SO WITH RESPECT TO THE
COMMISSION IN THE WAY, THE
COMMISSION'S ORGANIZED I'VE
LOOKED AT A COUPLE OF THEM. AND
IT SEEMS THAT, FOR EXAMPLE,
CALIFORNIA AS A MEMBER STATE
PARTICIPATING WOULD HAVE ONE
DELEGATE TO OUT OF, HOWEVER MANY
THERE ARE TO THE COMMISSION'S
BOARD. IS THAT TYPICALLY HOW IT
WORKS. YES ACROSS COMPACTS.
CALIFORNIA IS A MEMBER OF MANY
NATIONAL COMPACTS. THE MILITARY
CHILDREN'S COMPACT COMMISSION,
THE INTERSTATE JUVENILE COMPACT,
THE EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
ASSISTANCE COMPACT, AND THEY
HAVE ONE REPRESENTATIVE ON ALL
OF THOSE. IT'S THE SAME WITH THE
LICENSOR COMPACT AND IS THAT
DOES THAT REGARDLESS OF THE
NUMBER OF LICENSES THAT
CALIFORNIA'S CONTRIBUTING TO THE
PROCESS? YES EACH STATE UNDER
THE COMPACT COMMISSION MODEL, UH
, FOR THE LICENSOR COMPACTS AND
THEN OTHER COMPACTS. YES THEY
GET ONE DELEGATE. YES AND THEN I
NOTICED THAT IN IN A COUPLE OF
THE MODEL COMPACT SAID. I LOOKED
AT THAT THE COMMISSION HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO UM, LEAST PURCHASE
PROPERTY, BORROW MONEY AND ALL
OF THE REST AS PART OF ITS I
GUESS IT'S A 501, WHATEVER
NONPROFIT CORPORATION. IT'S A
GOVERNMENT AGENCY, A GOVERNMENT
AGENCY. OKAY SO AND THEN, OF
COURSE, THERE'S THE AUTHORITY OF
ASSESS AS YOU MENTIONED ANNUAL
ASSESSMENTS TO THE MEMBER STATES
, RIGHT? IS THERE ANY LIMITATION
ON THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT A
MEMBER STATE MIGHT BE ASSESSED?
BECAUSE I DIDN'T SEE IT IN THE
COMPACT? THAT WOULD BE
ESTABLISHED BY COMMISSION RULE.
UM IF THE COMMISSION WANTED TO
ESTABLISH THAT, UM, IT'S ALSO,
UM, YOU KNOW, THAT'S WHY EACH
STATE HAS A DELEGATE IS BECAUSE
YOU KNOW WHAT OTHER COMPACTS
HAVE FOUND IS THAT YOU KNOW,
STATES IT WOULD FALL TO THE
STATES OBVIOUSLY, TO PAY THAT
ASSESSMENT. AND SO, UH, YOU KNOW
THAT CHECK IS, UM, THOSE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE STATE ARE
GOING TO KEEP THOSE COSTS AS LOW
AS POSSIBLE. AGAIN YOU KNOW,
IT'S NOT JUST THE LICENSOR
COMPACTS THAT PROCESS OF ALL THE
NATIONAL COMPACTS ASSESS STATES
IN SOME WAY, AND YOU KNOW, I'M
NOT AWARE OF ANY STATES, LEAVING
BECAUSE OF ASSESSMENTS FROM FROM
THOSE COPIES DOES. THE
ASSESSMENT PROCESS TYPICALLY
INVOLVE A FORMULA THAT'S BASED
ON THE NUMBER OF LICENSES THAT
THE MEMBER STATE CONTRIBUTES TO
THE ISSUE OR PROBLEM. UM IT CAN.
YES IT CAN. LIKE I SAID NURSING
JUST CHARGES A STRAIGHT $6000 TO
EACH STATE'S AIPAC DOES HAVE A
SLIDING SCALE THAT'S BASED ON A
FORMULA. I KNOW THE INTERSTATE
COMPACT FOR THE PLACEMENT OF
CHILDREN HAS HAS A FORMULA. I'M
NOT SURE ABOUT THE OTHER. I
THINK THAT MILITARY CHILDREN'S
COMPACT COMMISSION ALSO HAS A
FORMULA. SO FOR EXAMPLE,
CALIFORNIA WOULD HAVE ONE VOTE
ON THE COMMISSION BOARD, BUT THE
ASSESSMENT COULD BE BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF LICENSES THAT WE
CONTRIBUTE. WHICH COULD BE HUGE
IN THE WELL, THE AGAIN, UH,
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE A HUGE PRIZE
FOR ANY OF THESE LICENSE OR
COMPACT. SO YOU KNOW, I DON'T
THINK THEY WOULD PRICE THEM OUT
OF OUT OF THE COMPACT. BUT YES
IF IT WAS BASED ON THE NUMBER OF
PRIVILEGES OR A NUMBER OF
LICENSEES, IT WOULD VERY LIKELY
BLOW LIKES AIPAC THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BASE IT ON THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE USING IT.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BASE IT ON
THE NUMBER OF LICENSING IN THE
STATE THAT I THINK THAT'S
INHERENTLY UNFAIR AND CALIFORNIA
WOULD WOULDN'T BE ALONG THERE.
OTHER OTHER LARGE STATES WOULD
ALSO PUSH BACK ON THAT, BUT YOU
KNOW IF A LARGE PERCENTAGE OF
CALIFORNIA PRACTITIONERS ARE
UTILIZING THE COMPACT AND THEN
YES, IT'S VERY LIKELY THEY WOULD
PAY HIGHER FEES THAN OTHERS ARE
BASED ON THE SIZE OF THE
POPULATION. IN THE FACT THAT
LICENSE YOU'RE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE COST OF IT.
UNFORTUNATELY A SYSTEM SET UP
LONG BEFORE ANY OF US GOT HERE.
IS BORN BY THE LICENSES
THEMSELVES, SO I ASSUME THAT ANY
CERTAINLY THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO GRAPPLE
WITH ANY ANNUAL ASSESSMENT TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE WAY
WE'VE CURRENTLY SCHEDULED THIS
INSTEAD, IT UP WOULD BE PASSED
ON TO THE CALIFORNIA LICENSES
AND THE ONES COMING IN TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE COULD CHARGE
THEM. FEES, SO WE'LL HAVE TO
FIGURE THAT OUT. DATA BREACH AND
CYBER SECURITY. I NOTICED THAT
THERE'S A DATA REPORTING
REQUIREMENT OF MEMBER STATES
DATA INDIVIDUALIZED DATA WITH
RESPECT TO LICENSEES THAT'S
MAINTAINED IN SOME CENTRAL DATA
SYSTEM, PRESUMABLY SOMEWHERE
IT'S NOT SAID IT WAS NOT SET OUT
IN ANY DETAIL IN THE COMPACTS
THAT I REVIEWED, BUT I'M JUST
WONDERING. I DIDN'T SEE ANY
PROVISION OR COMMITMENTS BY THE
COMMISSION REGARDING SUBJECT
THAT'S VERY, VERY SENSITIVE HERE
IN THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE,
AND THAT'S DATA PROTECTION. AND
DATA BREACH. UM WHERE WOULD I
FIND THE OBLIGATIONS AND
LIABILITY OF THE COMMISSION WITH
RESPECT TO THAT? GIVEN THE FACT
THAT THERE'S A CALL FOR DATA
WITH OR WITHOUT THE CONSENT OF
THE LICENSEE. YES SENATOR.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
MORE APPROPRIATE FOR COMMISSION
RULE WHETHER THAN THAN THE
CONTRACT AGAIN THE TERMS OF THE
CONTRACT CONTRACT. UM. IF YOU
WANT TO CHANGE THE TERMS OF THE
COMPACT, YOU WOULD HAVE TO
CHANGE THEM IN EVERY MEMBER
STATE, AND SO THEY GET SPECIFIC
ABOUT THOSE TYPES OF PROVISION
WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW
COULD IMPAIR THE ABILITY OF THE
COMPACT THAT OPERATE DOWN THE
ROAD. SO THAT'S MORE APPROPRIATE
, UM, FOR THE COMMISSION RULE
PROCESS. UH BUT I APPRECIATE YOU
RAISING THAT ISSUE, AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN GATHER
INFORMATION FROM THE CURRENT
LICENSURE COMPACT THAT ARE
OPERATING AND SEE AND GET YOU
THAT INFORMATION THAT THEY HAVE
JUST ONE FINAL QUESTION. I'VE
NOW EXHAUSTED MY CHAIR AND MY
COLLEAGUES PATIENTS, BUT ONE
FINAL, BUT NOT MINE. YOU HAVEN'T
EXHAUSTED. GOOD MAN, SIR. BUT
YOU'RE FROM THE SOUTH. SO THERE
YOU GO. ONE FINAL QUESTION ON
RULE MAKING. I NOTICED IN A
COUPLE OF THE COMPACTS THAT I
LOOKED AT UM ONE OF THEM IN
PARTICULAR CONTAINED THE
FOLLOWING RULES OF COMMISSION
SHALL HAVE THE FORCE OF LAW IN
EACH MEMBER STATE. NOW DOES THAT
MEAN THAT THE COMMISSION CAN
PASS A RULE BY I ASSUME A VOTE
OF THE COMMISSION BOARD, WHICH
CALIFORNIA WOULD HAVE ONE
DELEGATE ON THAT WOULD
CONSTITUTE A LAW IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND IF SO, HOW DOES
THAT WORK? WELL AGAIN. I'M NOT
AN ATTORNEY, UM I HOPE THIS
GIVES YOU SOME COMFORT. YES UM,
UM, YOU KNOW, COMPACTS ARE, UM
THESE ARE POWERFUL MECHANISMS
FOR STATES AND THEIR BINDING. UM
WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO FRAME HERE?
IS THAT AGAIN AS I AS I SAID, A
LITTLE EARLIER. THAT RULE MAKING
PROCESS IS IMPORTANT TO KEEP THE
COMPACT, YOU KNOW, OPERATING YOU
. YOU CAN'T GET SO SPECIFIC IN
THE LANGUAGE THAT, UM YOU KNOW
IT'S OUT OF DATE IN A FEW YEARS,
AND ITS PROVISIONS DON'T WORK.
SO YOU KNOW THAT RULEMAKING
POWER HAS TO BE, UH, SUBSTANTIAL
. THERE'S ALSO LANGUAGE IN THE
COMPACT THAT SAY, UM, I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT THE ONES THAT YOU
YOU'VE REVIEWED, BUT THE ONES
THAT THAT THAT WE'VE WRITTEN
UNDER THE DEAL, THE COOPERATIVE
AGREEMENT THAT, UM YOU KNOW ANY
RULE. THAT IT IS CONTRARY TO THE
SCOPE OR INTENT OF THE COMPACT
OUTSIDE. THE FOUR CORNERS OF THE
AGREEMENT IS DEEMED NOLAN BOY
THAT WOULDN'T STAND UP TO
JUDICIAL REVIEW AGAIN. THAT'S
NOT SAYING COMPACT COMMISSION
COULDN'T DO IT, BUT I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THEY WOULD. UM UH
THE COMPACT COMMISSION EXISTS
ONLY TO IMPLEMENT IT AND THEN
ADMINISTER THE COMPACT CAN'T
DICTATE POLICY TO THE STATES. UH
IT CAN'T YOU KNOW, TAKE
UNILATERAL ACTION AGAINST ANY
SORT OF PRACTITIONERS. SO BUT
YOU ARE CORRECT. I MEAN, YOU
KNOW, ONE OF THE REASONS THAT,
UM YOU KNOW THESE WORKS SO WELL
IS BECAUSE OF THEIR RULE MAKING
AUTHORITY. BUT IF IT GIVES YOU
ANY COMFORT THAT IS HIM THEN BY
JUDICIAL REVIEW BY PRESIDENT AND
BY THE LANGUAGE OF THE COMPACT
ABOUT YOU CAN'T GET OUTSIDE THE
SCOPE OR THE INTENT OF THE
COMPACT OR THE LABEL TO THE
CONFIDENT ONE FINAL ONE THING
THAT WITH RESPECT TO THIS IT WAS
A LITTLE CONCERNING TO ME, AND I
NOTICED PROVISION THAT SAID THAT
IT UNDER THE COMPACT, IT TAKES
THE MAJORITY OF THE LEGISLATURES
OF THE MEMBER STATES TAKING
ACTION BY PASSING A STATUTE. A
RESOLUTION TO REJECT THE RULE
ADOPTED BY THE COMMISSION, SO
THAT'S A LITTLE CUMBERSOME. IS
THAT A TYPICAL PROVISIONS IN
COMPACTS THAT YOU ALL PUT
TOGETHER? WELL IT'S A IT'S A
IT'S A TYPICAL PREVENT. YES IT
IS, AND IT'S ALSO JUST A TYPICAL
PROVISIONS OF THE COMPACTS. WELL
LISTEN, I APPRECIATE YOUR BEING
SO PATIENT AND RESPONDING TO MY
QUESTIONS. I ASSUME THAT MANY OF
THESE ISSUES ARE ISSUES THAT
COULD BE RESOLVED BY, UM,
NEGOTIATION OF THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
DECIDED TO PARTICIPATE IN ANY OR
ALL OF THESE, AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR FOR YOUR PATIENTS.
THANK YOU, SENATOR OFF FOR
ASKING A LOT OF REALLY GOOD
QUESTIONS THAT NEED TO BE ASKED.
WE THIS IS THIS IS THE POINT OF
THE INFORMATIONAL HEARING, SO
AND WE JUST WANT TO THANK YOU,
MR LUXON FOR JOINING US FROM
KENTUCKY TODAY. WE'RE THANKS FOR
LETTING US ASK YOU SOME HARD
QUESTIONS. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR EXPERTISE AND KNOWLEDGE ON
THE COMPACTS. WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO OUR NEXT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO OUR NEXT. YES, THANK YOU.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO OUR NEXT
SPEAKER. NOW I WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBERS FOR YOUR ROUND OF
QUESTIONS THERE TOO. THAT WAS
GREAT. OUR NEXT SPEAKER IS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. SO KIM KIRK MEYER.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE WITH US
TODAY. WE'RE GLAD TO HAVE YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM ASHBY. GOOD
MORNING. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE TODAY. AS YOU STATED, MY
NAME IS KIMBERLY KIRK MEYER AND
I DO SERVE AS THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS OR ALSO KNOWN AS D. C. A
D. C A IS THE STATE DEPARTMENT
THAT REGULATES PROFESSIONAL
LICENSING THROUGH 36 DIFFERENT
BOARDS AND BUREAUS. AND MORE
THAN 3.4 MILLION LICENSES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN 280
DIFFERENT LICENSE TYPES. THE CIA
UNDERSTANDS THE IMPORTANCE OF
PROFESSIONAL LICENSING AND THE
ABILITY TO PRACTICE AND MOST OF
ALL, DO YOU SEE A UNDERSTANDS
THE IMPORTANCE OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION? WE APPRECIATE THE
INVITATION TO BE HERE TODAY TO
JOIN YOU ON THIS DISCUSSION ON
INTERSTATE COMPACTS. BEFORE I
BEGIN. I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
ABOUT COM. BUT BEFORE I BEGIN TO
SPEAK ABOUT COMPACTS, I WOULD
LIKE TO JUST MAKE A FEW COMMENTS
ON ON SOMETHING THAT'S OF GREAT
INTEREST TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
TO THE DEPARTMENT AND THAT IS
CREATING OPPORTUNITIES AND
FLEXIBILITY FOR SERVICE MEMBERS
AND THEIR SPOUSES. A NEW FEDERAL
LAW WENT INTO EFFECT AS WE'VE
HEARD QUITE A BIT ABOUT TODAY.
ALREADY THAT WENT INTO EFFECT
JANUARY 1ST OF LAST YEAR RELATED
TO LICENSE PORTABILITY FOR
SERVICE MEMBERS AND THEIR
SPOUSES OR DOMESTIC PARTNERS TO
PRACTICE IN STATES WHERE THEY
ARE RELOCATED TO THE LICENSE
PORTABILITY ALLOWS THE THAT
INDIVIDUAL THE ABILITY TO
PRACTICE ADDRESSING THE NEED AND
CONCERN FOR SERVICE MEMBERS AND
THEIR SPOUSES. IN LIGHT OF THIS
RECENT CHANGE IN FEDERAL LAW,
INTERSTATE COMPACTS REALLY ARE
NOT NEEDED TO ACCOMPLISH THIS
GOAL FOR SERVICE MEMBERS AND
THEIR SPOUSES AND HAS FULLY
IMPLEMENTED THIS FEDERAL LAW AND
HAS AN EASY ONLINE REGISTRATION
PROCESS. AND I JUST CHECKED AND
WE HAVE 26 DIFFERENT INDIVIDUALS
WHO'VE ALREADY STARTED THAT
PROCESS SINCE WE BROUGHT IT UP
AND RUNNING IN THERE, SEVERAL
OTHERS WHO ARE PENDING THE
PROCESS AS THEY GO THROUGH NOW
TURNING TO COMPACTS, INTERSTATE
COMPACTS ARE LEGALLY BINDING,
LEGISLATIVE ENACTED CONTRACTS
AMONG STATES, ENABLING LICENSED
PROFESSIONALS TO PRACTICE IN ALL
STATES PARTICIPATING IN THAT
COMPACT. COMPACTS CAN ELIMINATE
SOME BARRIERS TO LICENSURE BY
ALLOWING AN AVENUE FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO GET LICENSED IN
ONE STATE AND ENTER THE
PROFESSION IN MULTIPLE STATES.
SOMETIMES BY PAYING ONLY ONE
STATE FEE. THIS CAN BE AN
ADVANTAGE FOR STATE
PARTICIPATING IN COMPACTS TO
QUICKLY ADDRESS ISSUES THAT MAY
COME UP DURING NATURAL DISASTERS
. AND WE REALIZE THERE IS
CONCERN REGARDING THESE
LICENSING COMPACTS. THIS TOPIC
IS VERY COMPLEX. IT'S A VERY
COMPLEX ONE, AND IT'S NOT ALL
COMPACTS ARE NOT IDENTICAL, AND
COMPACTS ARE NOT A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL SITUATION. COMPACTS ARE
SPECIFICALLY TAILORED TO EACH
PRACTICE AREA. SO A COMPACT
GOVERNING ONE PRACTICE WILL
USUALLY BE DIFFERENT FROM A
COMPACT GOVERNING A DIFFERENT
PRACTICE. AND AS I MENTIONED
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY HAS 36
DIFFERENT LICENSING BOARDS AND
BUREAUS THAT GOVERN ITS VARIOUS
PRACTICE AREAS. EVERY COMPACT IS
ALSO DIFFERENT IN WHAT IT ALLOWS
AND WHAT IT PROVIDES FOR BOTH
THE MEMBER STATE AND THE
LICENSEES. SOMETIMES IN A VERY
SIGNIFICANT WAY. COMPACTS CAN
DIFFER IN TERMS OF WHETHER
PRACTITIONERS NEED TO ACQUIRE A
SEPARATE LICENSE IN EACH STATE
OR MERELY OBTAIN A PRIVILEGE TO
PRACTICE IN EACH DAY BASED ON
THE LICENSE THEY ACQUIRED IN A
SINGLE STATE, OR WHETHER IT
REFERRED TO AS THE HOME STATE.
THEY CAN ALSO DIFFER IN TERMS OF
DISCIPLINARY AUTHORITY AND HOW
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS ARE
REPORTED. THESE VARIABLES RAISED
MAJOR POLICY QUESTIONS FOR EACH
COMPACT AND EACH LICENSE TYPE.
THEY ALSO RAISE CONSUMER
PROTECTION CONCERNS, ESPECIALLY
IN A STATE SUCH AS OURS, WHERE
WE PUT CONSUMER PROTECTION ABOVE
ALL ELSE, AND OUR CONSUMER
PROTECTION LEADERS. IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THE
MULTI STATE GOVERNING BODY
BEHIND COMPACTS. COMPACTS ARE
OFTEN OVERSEEN BY A COMMISSION
AS YOU HEARD A LOT ABOUT BY THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER, MADE UP OF
REPRESENTATIVES FROM COMPACT
MEMBER STATES. USUALLY EACH
STATE HAS ONE VOTE ON THE
COMMISSION, AND THE COMMISSION
ADOPTS AND AMENDS THE RULES
GOVERNING THE COLLECTIVE
PRACTICES OF ALL MEMBER STATES.
WELL PRESENTLY IN CALIFORNIA,
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE SLICES
EACH LICENSING BOARD ADOPTS THE
LAWS AND REGULATIONS THAT GOVERN
EACH PROFESSION UNDER A COMPACT
DYSFUNCTION IS LARGELY DELEGATED
TO THE COMMISSION. THIS MEANS
CALIFORNIA MAY BE
DISPROPORTIONATELY
UNDERREPRESENTED IN EACH
COMPACT. WHICH CAN BE
PROBLEMATIC AS CALIFORNIA'S
LICENSING POPULATIONS ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN OTHER
STATES IN ALMOST EVERY CATEGORY.
IT'S ALSO FAIR TO SAY THAT
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS MIGHT ALSO
BE AFFECTED SINCE OUR STATE IS
ONE OF THE MOST POPULOUS IN THE
NATION. CALIFORNIA ONLY HAS ONE
VOTE THERE, MAYBE CONSUMER
PROTECTION CONCERNS AS THE RULES
AND BYLAWS ADOPTED BY THE
COMMISSION COULD BE CHANGED IN
CALIFORNIA WOULD GENERALLY BE
OBLIGATED TO ABIDE BY THE RULES
UNLESS IT WITHDRAWS FROM THE
COMPACT. IN ADDITION TO A
COMMISSION, SOME COMPACTS
ACTUALLY HAVE A SMALLER BOARD OF
DIRECTORS USUALLY MADE UP OF
COMMISSION MEMBERS WHO CAN HAVE
DECISION MAKING DELEGATED TO
THEM. THAT'S COMPLETELY
CIRCUMVENTING THE MEMBER STATES
FROM BEING ABLE TO BE INVOLVED
IN CERTAIN PROVISIONS OF THAT
COMPACT. ONE OTHER IMPORTANT
FACT ABOUT THE COMMISSION IS
THAT THEY OFTEN DO NOT HAVE
REQUIREMENTS ABOUT THE
MEMBERSHIP THEY MAKE THAT'S MADE
UP OF THAT COMMISSION. EACH
MEMBER BOARD WILL DELEGATE A
MEMBER TO THE COMMISSION IF ALL
MEMBERS DELEGATE A LICENSEE
BOARD MEMBER, THE COMMISSION
WILL BE MADE UP OF ALL LICENSES
WHO ARE MAKING DECISIONS FOR
CONSUMER PROTECTION BOARDS. IN
CALIFORNIA ARE BOARDS ARE MIX OF
LICENSING AND PUBLIC MEMBERS, SO
I'LL PERSPECTIVES CAN BE HEARD
AND THAT CONSUMER VIEWPOINT IS
BROUGHT FORWARD. THE COMMISSION
SHOULD HAVE REQUIREMENT THAT THE
COMMISSION HAVE A BALANCE OF
BOTH LICENSING AND PUBLIC
MEMBERS. BASED ON CALIFORNIA'S
LICENSING AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND CONSUMER
POPULATION SIZE, CALIFORNIA'S
VOTE AND VOICE IN GOVERNING
RULES OF THE COMPACT SHOULD BE
REFLECTIVE OF THE CALIFORNIA'S
SIZE. AND I THINK THAT SENATOR
WRATH KIND OF EXPLAINING THAT IT
IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
ONCE A STATE ENTERS A COMPACT,
IT USUALLY TAKES A LEGISLATIVE
ACT WITHDRAW FROM IT, WHICH MAY
BE DIFFICULT TO DO ONCE THE
STATE HAS COMMITTED SUBSTANTIAL
RESOURCES TO THAT NEW COMPACT
AND THAT GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE.
ALSO, IT IS DIFFICULT TO REMOVE
NONCOMPLIANT STATES FROM
COMPACTS. SO EVEN IN A SITUATION
WHERE ANOTHER STATE MAY BE
FLOUTING THAT AGREED UPON
COMPACT ROLLS, CALIFORNIA WOULD
HAVE LIMITED OPTIONS TO SEVER
THOSE TIES WITH NONCOMPLIANT
STATES. IN CALIFORNIA. LICENSING
BOARDS ARE SPECIALLY FUNDED,
MEANING FUNDING COMES FROM THE
LICENSE FEES. WHILE SOME
COMPACTS REQUIRE APPLICANTS TO
PAY FEES TO PRACTICE IN EACH
STATE, OTHERS ARE SET UP LIKE A
DRIVER'S LICENSE, AND THAT THE
FEES ARE ONLY PAID TO THAT HOME
STATE AND SOMETIMES TO THE F E
TO THE COMPACTS GOVERNING BODY
LIKE THAT COMMISSION. AT WHICH
POINT THE INDIVIDUAL CAN THEN
PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA. THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD, THEN HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENFORCE THE
LAWS AMONG A LARGER LICENSEE
POPULATION BUT MAY NOT RECEIVE
THE FULL FUNDING NEEDED TO DO
SO. LICENSURE AND RENEWAL FEES
SHOULD BE PAID TO THE BOARD OR
BUREAU IN CALIFORNIA. FEES
CANNOT ALL GO TO THE COMMISSION,
OR ONLY TO THE HOME STATE. THESE
NEED TO COVER ENFORCEMENT COSTS
OR ONLY THE UM OR ONLY
CALIFORNIA LICENSES ARE GOING TO
BE PAYING FOR INVESTIGATING
CASES FOR INDIVIDUALS NOT
LICENSED IN THIS STATE. THE
ABILITY TO BE A CONTRIBUTOR TO
DRAFTING OR CHANGING LANGUAGE IN
A COMPACT TO ADDRESS LICENSING
STANDARDS AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION CONCERNS IS AN
IMPORTANT FACTOR FOR ANY COMPACT
TO BE CONSIDERED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER. CALIFORNIA IS A
CONSUMER PROTECTION LEADER AND
STUMP STATES IN SOME PROFESSIONS
, CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY HAS A
HIGHER LICENSING STANDARDS AND
OTHER STATES, INCLUDING A
REQUIREMENT FOR FINGERPRINTS.
AMONGST NUMEROUS OF OUR
PROFESSIONS, AND IT IS THESE
STANDARDS THAT SHOULD BE USED
FOR ANY COMPACT CALIFORNIA IS
CONSIDERING TO JOIN. ALSO IN
ORDER TO BE ELIGIBLE TO PRACTICE
UNDER LICENSURE COMPACT IN
CALIFORNIA, A LICENSEE SHOULD
HAVE AN UNRESTRICTED LICENSE IN
GOOD STANDING AND OTHER STATES.
SUBSEQUENT ARREST. RECORDS ALSO
NEED TO BE SHARED WITH ALL
STATES IN THAT COMPACT. IN
CALIFORNIA APPLICANTS CAN
PROVIDE AN INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER TO THE
LICENSING BOARDS IN LUANDA
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER AND STILL
BE ELIGIBLE FOR LICENSURE. SOME
STATES REQUIRE SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS FOR LICENSURE. THIS
ISSUE WOULD NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
IN ANY COMPACT THAT CALIFORNIA
IS LOOKING AT. FOR THOSE
LICENSES THAT DO NOT TAKE
NATIONAL EXAMS. THE EXAMINATION
REQUIREMENTS SHOULD BE
EQUIVALENT TO CALIFORNIA'S
EXAMINATION REQUIREMENTS,
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC
LAW AND ETHICS EXAMINATION
REQUIREMENTS. THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HAS ADOPTED SEVERAL
LAWS THAT ARE IMPORTANT FOR
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND MAYBE
MORE STRINGENT AND DIFFERENT
FROM OTHER STATES, FOR EXAMPLE,
IN THE ARCHITECTURE, ENGINEERING
AND PHARMACY INDUSTRIES. THIS IS
WHY SPECIFIC CALIFORNIA LAW
EXAMINATIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE THOSE PRACTICING AND
CALIFORNIA ARE AWARE OF THE LAWS
AND THAT THEY ARE FOLLOWING THEM
WHEN PROVIDING SERVICES TO
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS. FOR SOME
LICENSE TYPES. THERE ARE SPECIAL
AND SPECIFIC, CONTINUING
EDUCATION THAT IS REQUIRED HERE
IN CALIFORNIA, SUCH AS IMPLICIT
BIAS DISCRIMINATION TRAINING,
ETCETERA, AND IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT THESE
WILL BE REQUIRED FOR THOSE
LICENSES COME INTO PRACTICE IN
CALIFORNIA UNDER THE COMPACTS.
ANY COMPACT THAT CALIFORNIA
CONSIDERS SHOULD TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THAT THERE ARE
DIFFERENCES IN THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE OR WHAT SERVICES AND
INDIVIDUAL IS AUTHORIZED TO
PROVIDE UNDER LICENSE FROM STATE
TO STATE FOR SOME PROFESSIONS,
THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE IN
CALIFORNIA MAYBE BROADER, UM
THAN IN OTHER STATES AND THE
INDIVIDUALS COMING INTO
CALIFORNIA DO NOT HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE TRAINING. TO PERFORM
THOSE EXPANDED FUNCTIONS.
CONVERSELY FOR SOME PROFESSIONS
TO SCOPE OF PRACTICE IN
CALIFORNIA IS ACTUALLY MORE
RESTRICTIVE THAN IN OTHER STATES
. FOR EXAMPLE, IN OTHER STATES,
SOME HEALING ARTS LICENSES CAN
PRESCRIBE MEDICATION, BUT THEY
CANNOT PRESCRIBE IN CALIFORNIA.
SOME LICENSES IN CALIFORNIA CAN
PERFORM EXPANDED FUNCTIONS WITH
ADDITIONAL TRAINING, BUT THEY
CANNOT PERFORM THOSE FUNCTIONS
IN OTHER STATES. THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
IN ANY COMPACT TO ENSURE THAT
LICENSES ARE TRAINED AND HAVE
KNOWLEDGE IN ANY SERVICES THAT
CALIFORNIA ALLOWS THEM TO BE TO
BE PRACTICED. ENFORCEMENT IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF ANY
COMPACT IN ORDER TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS, CALIFORNIA BOARDS AND
BUREAUS SHOULD BE ABLE TO TAKE
DISCIPLINARY ACTION AGAINST THE
LICENSING, PRACTICING AND
CALIFORNIA EVEN IF CALIFORNIA IS
NOT THE HOME STATE. THE
INABILITY TO TAKE DISCIPLINARY
ACTION SHOULD BE CONSIDERED NON
NEGOTIABLE FOR OUR STATE. NOT
ONLY THE ABILITY TO TAKE ACTION,
BUT TAKE THE ACTION THAT
CALIFORNIA WANTS TO TAKE AND NOT
BE REQUIRED TO MIRROR THAT OF
THE HOME, STATE OR OTHER ANOTHER
STATE TAKES ADDITIONALLY WITH
THE INFLUX OF NEW PRACTITIONERS,
ENFORCEMENT RESPONSIBILITIES MAY
INCREASE FOR BOARDS AND BUREAUS,
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
AND THE OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS. ALL OF THIS INCREASES
COST TO THE BOARDS AND BUREAUS,
WHICH MUST BE COVERED BY
LICENSING FEES. BEST LICENSING
FEES MAY INCREASE. DISCIPLINE
TAKEN BY ANY STATE IN THE
COMPACT AS WELL AS THE COMPLAINT
AND INVESTIGATION FILED NEEDS TO
BE DISCLOSED WITH HOME STATES
AND ALL OTHER STATES IN THE
COMPACT. DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS
AND WHEN DISCIPLINE MAY BE TAKEN
WILL DIFFER ACROSS STATES. THIS
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED. IN
ADDITION, SOMETHING ACTUALLY
COULD BE PRETTY PROHIBITED IN
ANOTHER STATE, SUCH AS
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES,
BUT ALLOWED IN CALIFORNIA OR
PROHIBITED IN CALIFORNIA, SUCH
AS GENDER CONVERSION THERAPY,
BUT ALLOWED FOR IN OTHER STATES.
THESE ARE A FEW EXAMPLES OF
UNIQUE AND SPECIFIC ISSUES THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED IN ANY
COMPACT. THERE ARE ALTERNATIVES
TO COMPACTS THAT ACCOMPLISHED
MANY OF THE SAME GOALS. FOR
INSTANCE, THE ACCOUNTANCY
PROFESSION HAS WHAT IS CALLED
PRACTICE PRIVILEGE OR MOBILITY.
THIS PROFESSION USES SUBSTANTIAL
EQUIVALENCY OF EDUCATION,
EXAMINATION AND EXPERIENCE AS
THE FOUNDATIONAL ELEMENTS FOR
CROSS BORDER PRACTICE FOR
REGULATING BODIES ACROSS THE
NATION, INCLUDING CALIFORNIA.
UNLIKE INTERSTATE COMPACTS THAT
REQUIRE APPROVAL BY MULTIPLE
STATE LEGISLATURES, AND ONCE
APPROVED, CANNOT BE CHANGED
PURSUANT TO THE STATUTE, THE
BOARD OF ACCOUNTANCY RETAINS
THEIR AUTHORITY AND RECEIVED
STATES, THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
REVIEW STATES DISCIPLINARY
PROCESSES TO ENSURE THEY ARE
APPROPRIATE. THE BOARD ALSO
MAINTAINS THE FLEXIBILITY TO
VOTE TO REMOVE A STATE FROM THE
PRACTICE PRIVILEGE LIST. ANOTHER
VIABLE WAY FOR LICENSE
PORTABILITY IS THROUGH
RECIPROCITY, WHICH CAN BE DONE
BY STATUTE. THIS APPROACH
MAINTAINS THE OVERSIGHT BY THE
CALIFORNIA BORDER BUREAU AND
WOULD ALLOW FOR A QUICKER
PATHWAY TO LICENSE. SURE.
CURRENTLY 17 OF THE 36 BOARDS
AND BUREAUS UNDER DECIA ALSO
ALREADY OFFER SOME FORM OF
RECIPROCITY ALREADY. THE POINT
THAT I'D LIKE TO DRIVE HOME WITH
THIS INFORMATION IS THAT I'VE
ALREADY SHARED TODAY IS THAT
COMPACTS ARE NOT A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL SOLUTION. THERE ARE MANY
FACTORS THAT COME INTO PLAY,
INCLUDING THE PRIORITIES OF
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND
LICENSING STANDARDS THAT SHOULD
NOT BE COMPROMISED OR LOWERED
FOR CALIFORNIANS AND THE
LEGISLATURE AND BOARD SHOULD
HAVE AUTONOMY. DC I UNDERSTANDS
THAT INDIVIDUALS WANT TO BE
LICENSED AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
AND HAS IMPLEMENTED EXPEDITED
LICENSURE AND EVEN TEMPORARY
LICENSE SHIRT TO ASSIST WITH
THIS ISSUE, AND IT'S ALWAYS
LOOKING AT WAYS TO REDUCE
LICENSING BARRIERS. THE
DEPARTMENT LOOKS FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON ANY OF THESE
ISSUES, AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT THROW OVERVIEW. I DO WANT
TO OPEN IT UP TO MY COLLEAGUES
AND I HAVE A COUPLE OF QUICK
QUESTIONS TILL YOU YOU. YOU
TOUCHED ON THIS A BIT, BUT I
THINK YOU KNOW ONE QUESTION THAT
EVERY LEGISLATOR ASKS WHEN
PRESENTED WITH SOMETHING LIKE
THIS IS WHAT IS THE PROBLEM
WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE FOR AND
WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS A GOOD
FIT FOR OUR STATE AND FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT WE REPRESENT SO SORT
OF TRYING TO DIG INTO THAT AT
THE ROOT OF THIS QUESTION. UM WE
KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA'S BEEN
ASKED TO ENTER VARIOUS COMPACTS.
THE LAST SPEAKER, OF COURSE,
CALLED A SURPRISE WHICH WE KNOW
RIGHT? THAT'S WHY WE'RE BEING SO
DEFENSIVE. OF COURSE, RIGHT.
THAT'S CALIFORNIA. WE KNOW THAT
WE WOULD HAVE A LOT TO OFFER,
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
OFFER TO OUR OWN FOLKS FIRST,
AND WE TAKE CARE OF PEOPLE HERE
AND THAT THEY HAVE LOTS OF
OPPORTUNITY. SO MY QUESTION FOR
YOU IS IT JUST STRIKES ME HOW
THE DIFFERENCE IN HOW
ENFORCEMENT WOULD BE HANDLED AND
WHAT POWER. WE WOULD BE SEATING
NOT JUST FOR ENFORCEMENT. BUT
LIKE YOU SAID, UH, NOT BEING
ABLE TO DEAL WITH STATES THAT
AREN'T BEING GOOD ACTORS BECAUSE
WE DON'T HOLD ALL THE CARDS IN A
COMPACT. IT'S A IT'S AN EQUAL,
IT'S NOT. IT'S NOT LIKE A
CONTRACT BETWEEN TWO PEOPLE
WHERE ONE CAN ENFORCE EASILY
AGAINST THE OTHER COMPACT IS
DIFFERENT FROM THAT RECIPROCITY
IS MORE LIKE THAT. SO WHAT
PROVISIONS DO YOU THINK THESE
COMPACTS NEED? IN ORDER FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO IN ANY WAY JUSTIFY
ENTERING INTO THEM. AND DO YOU
THINK THERE IS LIKE ONE AREA?
THAT MAYBE WE WOULD BENEFIT FROM
COMPACTS AND OTHER AREAS WHERE
YOU THINK IT MIGHT NOT MAKE
SENSE. ONE THING THAT WAS
ALREADY MENTIONED EARLIER TO,
FOR EXAMPLE, THERE ARE SOME
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE BEING
DISCUSSED AS COMPACTS HERE.
WHERE REALLY, IF YOU MOVE HERE,
YOU JUST PAY A PRETTY NOMINAL
LICENSURE FEE AND YOU'RE IN, SO
I'M NOT SURE WHY WE WOULD CREATE
AN ENTIRE NEW LEVEL OF SORT OF
NATIONAL, UM, BUREAUCRACY THAT.
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THERE'S A REAL
PROBLEM FOR SOLUTION THERE. SO
CAN YOU MAYBE ADDRESS THAT PIECE
? TELL US LIKE HOW AND WHERE IS
THIS RELEVANT FOR US? AND HOW DO
WE PROTECT OUR CALIFORNIA
STANDARDS? OKAY. UM I THINK I'VE
KIND OF GONE OVER IN A LOT OF MY
TALKING POINTS OF THE THINGS
THAT WE THINK ARE IMPORTANT IN
ANY COMPACT THAT YOU'RE LOOKING
AT, AND WHAT IS IMPORTANT FOR
CONSUMER PROTECTION. AND
OBVIOUSLY, AS YOU STATED,
ENFORCEMENT IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST THINGS RIGHT. WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
TAKE ACTION AGAINST AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S PRACTICING HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND POTENTIALLY
COULD HARM EITHER FINANCIALLY OR
PHYSICALLY. ONE OF OUR CONSUMERS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA, SO YOU WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
TAKE ACTION? I THINK RISK. YOU
KNOW HOW AND WHERE IT'S
RELEVANT. I THINK IT'S THE
DECISION OF THE LICENSEE. YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE LICENSING. WHAT'S
THE EASIEST FOR THEM, AND THAT'S
WHERE A LOT OF THESE ARE
RELEVANT RIGHT? BECAUSE AN
INDIVIDUAL CAN CHOOSE THAT
ABILITY TO JOIN A COMPACT IN
ANOTHER STATE, AND THEN ALLOWS
THEM JUST AUTOMATICALLY TO COME
HERE AND TO CALIFORNIA. UM THE
BIG ONE OF THE OTHER BIG THINGS
THAT I THINK IS IN THE LICENSE.
HE GETS THE BENEFIT OF IF THEY
POTENTIALLY COULD ONLY PAY ONE
LICENSE FEE. THEY DON'T HAVE TO
PAY THOSE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
YOU'D PAY THAT ONE FEE YOU'D GET
TO COME INTO AND PRACTICE INTO
CALIFORNIA. THE AS SENATOR ROSS
SO ELOQUENTLY STATED EARLIER.
OUR FEES ARE SET UP POTENTIALLY
VERY DIFFERENTLY FROM OTHER
STATES. OTHER STATES SOMETIMES
HAVE A DIFFERENT FEAST. GET
STRUCTURE THAN THAT THEY ARE
SPECIALLY FUNDED BY THE
LICENSING FEES. SO I THINK THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING WHILE IT MIGHT
BE A BENEFIT TO THE LICENSEE, IS
IT A BENEFIT TO HEARING AS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA? IF WE'RE NOT
GETTING THE FEES THAT ALLOW US
TO DO OUR ROLE OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND ENFORCEMENT, THEN
NO, OBVIOUSLY, THAT WOULDN'T BE
A BENEFIT TO US HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, I THINK THIS IS THE
SCOPE OF PRACTICE IS USUALLY
KIND OF SET ALREADY IN IN A LOT
OF THE COMPACTS AT THE BEGINNING
OR STATE THAT IT FOLLOWS THE
STATE'S COMPACT I'M STILL
FOLLOWS THE STATE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE OR THE RULES HERE. BUT
IF YOU READ THROUGH A LOT OF THE
COMPACTS, A LOT OF THE THINGS
ARE DEVELOPED BY THE RULE OF THE
COMMISSION. SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THOSE COMPACTS, YOU LOOK AT WHAT
IS THE RULE OF THE COMMISSION.
THAT'S BEING ALLOWED TO BE
CHANGED. SO I THINK THAT'S
ANOTHER THING YOU REALLY NEED TO
LOOK AT. WHEN YOU'RE ENTERING
THOSE COMPACTS. I THINK THAT
SENATOR ROCK DID A GREAT EXAMPLE
OF LOOKING AT A COMPACT AND
POINTING OUT THOSE AREAS WHERE
THERE IS CONCERN. NOT ONLY FOR,
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA BUT FOR
CONSUMER PROTECTION, AND I THINK
A LOT OF THOSE THAT'S THAT'S
WHERE YOU HAVE TO FOCUS IS
REALLY PULLING APART THOSE
INDIVIDUAL COMPACTS AND LOOKING
AT THE PROS AND CONS OF THEM AND
SEEING IF IT IS THE BEST THING
HERE FOR THE STATE. OKAY?
COLLEAGUES. SENATOR DODD. YES
QUESTION FIRST. I MEAN WHAT I
HEARD HERE. I'VE HEARD A LOT
HERE AND, UM THERE'S 36
DIFFERENT BOARDS IN THE STATE.
CAN WE PICK AND CHOOSE CHERRY
PICK IF YOU USE THAT TERM ON
WHICH COMPACTS WE WOULD WANT TO
ENTER INTO. YOU DO HAVE THAT
ABILITY AS THE LEGISLATION
BECAUSE EVERY ONE OF THESE
COMPACTS HAS TO GO THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE TO CHOOSE THE WAY
THESE COMPACTS ARE SET UP. THEY
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. AND WHILE I
DO AGREE THAT CALIFORNIA IS
DIFFERENT, I JUST TAKE EXCEPTION
TO THE FACT THAT A PROFESSIONAL
DOT LICENSED DOCTOR OR NURSE OR
TEACHER IN ANY OTHER STATE,
THEY'RE ALL OUT IN ALL IN FOR
PROTECTING. THERE ARE PATIENTS
FOR HELPING THEM, BLAH, BLAH,
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH. SO I'M NOT A
BIG BELIEVER IN THAT NOBODY ELSE
CAN DO IT BETTER THAN CALIFORNIA
WHILE I DO BELIEVE WE'RE DOING A
GOOD JOB, SO I GUESS FOR ME IF
WE'RE GOING TO ENTER INTO SOME
OF THESE COMPACTS IT IT PROBABLY
SHOULD BE BASED ON METRICS THAT
WE HAVE. WHERE DO WE HAVE A
NEED, AND MAYBE THEY'RE NOT LONG
TERM. DO WE HAVE A KNEE RIGHT
NOW? FOR TEACHERS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA? HOW MANY TEACHERS
DID WE HAVE FIVE YEARS AGO? HOW
MANY WE HAVE TODAY? POST COVID
ALL THESE POST COVID NURSES,
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS,
DOCTORS, OTHER HEALTH OFFICIALS
AND SO TO ME THAT WOULD GUIDE MY
THINKING, AND THAT'S ABOUT AS
MUCH AS I WANT TO HAVE TO DO
WITH THIS BECAUSE THIS IS, UH
YOU KNOW SOMETHING THAT THIS GUY
UNDERSTANDS A LOT BETTER THAN I
DO. THANK YOU RIGHT OUT. OKAY
SENATOR ARCHULETTA. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR YOUR YOUR INFORMATION.
MY GOD, THAT WAS QUITE A BIT,
BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE EDUCATIONAL
STANDARDS OF COMING IN AND HOW
WE ARE PROTECTING OUR CONSUMERS
ARE GENERAL PUBLIC. AND AS WE
JUST HEARD, MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED THAT SERIES OF
PROFESSIONALS BUT THEY ALSO
PRACTICED OVER THERE AND
WHATEVER STATE BUT, UH, SHOULD
SHOULD WE HAVE SOME RULES THAT
WE DO A LITTLE BETTING PRIOR TO
ISSUING THE LICENSE. IS THAT
WHAT YOUR CONCERN IS? OR IS IT
JUST THE FEES THAT YOU CAN?
WHAT'S YOUR PRIMARY CONCERN? IT
SOUNDS TO ME LIKE MORE THE
EDUCATIONAL STANDARDS. YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. SENATOR
ARTICULATE AND FEES ARE ONE
PIECE OF IT. BUT YOU WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE INDIVIDUALS
COMING IN HERE IS COMPETENT TO
PRACTICE AND THAT THEY MEET THE
COMPETENCY REQUIREMENTS THAT YOU
HAVE SET IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS FOR WHAT THOSE
REQUIREMENTS ARE, I THINK IN
LOOKING AT LIKE HOW THE
ACCOUNTANCY BOARD WAS SET UP
WITH THEIR PRACTICE PRIVILEGE
THEY LOOKED AT. I THINK THEY
CALL IT THE THREES AND THEY HAVE
AN ORGANIZATION THAT LOOKS LIKE
THAT. IT'S EDUCATION EXAMINATION
AND, UM, EXPERIENCE. AND WHAT
REQUIREMENTS HAVE BEEN SET UP
ALREADY HEARING IN CALIFORNIA
THAT IS SOMETHING YOU WANT TO
LOOK AT. YOU KNOW, BECAUSE ONE
OF THE CONCERNS AS IF AND AGAIN
ALL OF THESE COMPLEX ARE SO
DIFFERENT AND HOW THEY HAVE BEEN
SET UP. SO THAT'S WHY YOU REALLY
NEED TO LOOK AT HOW IT WAS SET
UP AND WHAT THEIR REQUIREMENTS
ARE. SOME OF THEM ARE ACTUALLY
STRONGER THAN CALIFORNIA. NOT A
LOT OF THEM, BUT PROBABLY
THERE'S A FEW OF THEM THAT I
KNOW OF. BUT ON THE FLIP SIDE,
WHAT AREN'T WHAT HAVEN'T THEY
SAID? THAT IS IN THERE THAT WE
ACTUALLY HAVE. SO IF WE HAVE, IF
A PERSON IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
GO TO THE LOWEST DENOMINATOR
STATE AND BE LICENSED THE STATE
THAT HAS THE LOWEST REQUIREMENTS
FOR LICENSURE AND THEN BE ABLE
TO COME IN HERE AND PRACTICE IN
CALIFORNIA, THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING YOU SHOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT. BECAUSE THEY
HAVEN'T MET THE REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE ALREADY BEEN
ESTABLISHED HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THAT THE LEGISLATIVE BODY ITSELF
HAS SAID THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR
CALIFORNIA AGAIN CONSUMERS TO
HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
COMPETENT TO PRACTICE. HOW WOULD
WHAT WOULD BE THE FIRST STEP?
OBVIOUSLY IF THERE'S A NEED FOR
TEACHERS AND NEED FOR PHYSICIANS
OR WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE, AND
WE'RE TRYING TO EXPEDITE
ANYTHING. HOW CAN WE DO THE
VETTING? VERIFY THE EDUCATIONAL
STANDARDS AND OPEN UP THOSE
DOORS TO FULFILL OUR NEEDS? SO
THERE'S A COUPLE OF THINGS FIRST
OF ALL FOR THE ENTITIES THAT
HAVE RECIPROCITY. THERE IS
REALLY MAKING SURE THAT US AS
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS, WE'RE GETTING THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THROUGH THE PROCESS
AND LICENSES QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
. I THINK FOR GETTING PEOPLE
INTO CALIFORNIA I THINK WE HAVE
A GOOD PROCESS THAT'S ALREADY
HERE THAT INDIVIDUALS CAN FOLLOW
AND GET LICENSED. AND NOW
ESPECIALLY FOR I KNOW THAT WE'RE
ALWAYS TALKING ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
SERVICE MEMBERS AND THEIR
SPOUSES WITH THE NEW PROCESS.
IT'S A LOT FASTER TO COME IN FOR
THEM AND BE ABLE JUST TO PROVIDE
PROOF THAT THEY'RE LICENSED IN
THIS OTHER STATE, AND THEY HAVE
THESE ORDER. SO THAT'S A BEEN
BEEN A BIG BENEFIT FOR THEM.
AYE. I THINK AT THE END OF THE
DAY, IT'S KIND OF WHEN YOU GET
THESE COMPACTS THAT COME BEFORE
YOU AND INDIVIDUALS ARE SAYING
WE NEED MORE LICENSES. YOU DO
HAVE TO DRILL DOWN AND LOOK AT
WHAT ARE THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
THAT LICENSE DURING COMPARE THEM
TO WHAT CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY
PUT IN PLACE AND SEE. ARE THESE
INDIVIDUALS THAT YOU WANT TO
HAVE PRACTICING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BASED ON THEIR THEIR
TRAINING THAT THEY HAVE
RECEIVED? BECAUSE UNLIKE A LOT
OF RECIPROCITY BILLS THAT THAT
WE SEE OR THAT WE HAVE ACTUALLY
LAWS NOW. OH SOMETIMES, EVEN IN
THOSE THEY REQUIRED THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS NOT ONLY LICENSED IN
THE OTHER STATEMENT, MAYBE
THEY'RE PRACTICING FOR A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF TIME AS WELL. AND THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY DISCIPLINARY
ACTION. THAT'S HOW A LOT OF
RECIPROCITY IS SET UP. SO IF YOU
ALLOW AN INDIVIDUAL TO GO AND
GET LICENSED AT ONE OF THESE
MINIMAL LICENSURE STATES THEY
GET LICENSED THERE. THERE'S NO
POTENTIALLY REQUIREMENT FOR ANY
TIME OF PRACTICE FOR THEM TO BE
THERE AND THEN TO COME INTO
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU, SENATOR
NILO. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I
DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THIS.
PRIOR TO THE HEARING PRIOR TO
GETTING THIS PACKET, NOR DID I
HAVE A GREAT DEAL OF TIME. TO
REVIEW IT AHEAD OF TIME. SO I'M
LEARNING ALL THIS, UH, NOW
CURRENTLY AND TRYING TO PROCESS
IT, BUT KIND OF PIGGYBACKING ON
SENATOR DODD'S COMMENTS. IT
SEEMS TO ME THE REASON FOR, UH,
COMPACTS THE BENEFIT TO
CALIFORNIA. IS ADDITIONAL
COMPETITION COMPETITION AND
THEREFORE BENEFITS TO CONSUMERS,
AS OPPOSED TO PRIMARILY OFFERING
OPPORTUNITIES TO PRACTITIONERS
THAT ARE LICENSED HERE AND THEN
COULD, UM AND BEYOND THAT, UH,
IT SEEMS THAT THE ALLOWANCE. FOR
PRACTICING IN STATE IS VERY
EPISODIC. IN OTHER WORDS,
TRANSIENT. PEOPLE COMING IN HERE
TO PROVIDE, UM, SERVICES
TEMPORARILY AND THEN LEAVING
THAT DOESN'T DO ANYTHING TO
SATISFY THE DEMAND THAT WE HAVE
FOR PROFESSIONS LIKE MEDICAL. UH
PROVIDERS AND TEACHERS AND THE
LIKE, TO THE EXTENT THAT WE ARE
LACKING ON THE SUPPLY SIDE THERE
WE NEED PEOPLE LIVING HERE AND
PROVIDING THAT SERVICE. IT SEEMS
TO ME COMPACTS AREN'T DESIGNED
TO DO THAT. SO I'M NOT TERRIBLY
ENTHUSED. NOR DO I GATHER THAT
YOUR TESTIMONY IS A RESOUNDING
ENDORSEMENT OF THE OF THE
ARRANGEMENT SO I COULD SEE WHERE
THERE ARE SOME BENEFITS AND SOME
AREAS WHERE CONSUMERS HERE WOULD
HAVE ADDITIONAL ADDITIONAL
CONSUMING OPPORTUNITIES
EPISODICALLY, BUT IN TERMS OF,
UM IT DOES NOT APPEAR TO ME TO
BE IN ANY WAY OR TOO OLD TO
SATISFY, UM THE SHORTAGE THAT WE
HAVE OF CERTAIN PROFESSIONS OF
WHICH THERE ARE A LOT, UH, EVEN
AUTO MECHANICS AS AN EXAMPLE. SO
THANK YOU. AND I DO AGREE. I
MEAN, I THINK AT THE END OF THE
DAY, ONE SIDE OR THE OTHER,
WHETHER WE'RE SUPPORT OR NOT
SUPPORTIVE COMPACTS IS KIND OF
IRRELEVANT. IT'S CONSUMER
PROTECTION AT THE END OF THE DAY
AND MAKING SURE IF THERE IS A
COMPACT THAT COMES IN THAT IT'S
DOING THE BEST FOR OUR
CONSUMERS. SENATOR BECKER. YEAH
I JUST WANT TO END THAT IT
RIGHT. LET'S APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION. I DIDN'T KNOW, UM A
LOT ABOUT THIS PREVIOUSLY. I
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION AND
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
AND I THINK IT IS A BALANCE AT
THE END OF THE DAY, RIGHT? UM
AND, UM, YOU KNOW, HOLDING OUR
STANDARDS. UM ALTHOUGH, YOU KNOW
, AT THE SAME TIME AS PER THE
HOOVER CONCERN, MAKING SURE THAT
WE MAKE THEM AS MANAGEABLE AS
POSSIBLE WHILE STILL PROTECTING
CONSUMERS. UM YOU KNOW, WHILE
MAKING SURE THAT WE, YOU KNOW,
WE DO HAVE ENOUGH ROLES TO FILL
THIS THESE POSITIONS AND I THINK
TOO SOONER. NEIL'S POINT WE
DON'T NECESSARILY PEOPLE COME IN
LIKE THAT THE WHOLE SORT OF
TRAVEL NURSE PHENOMENON.
HOPEFULLY WE HAVE ENOUGH NURSES
HERE, FOR EXAMPLE, JUST
DIFFERENT AREA, UM, TO FILL
THOSE NEEDS, BUT I DON'T THINK
WE CAN SAY FOR SURE THAT MOST
PEOPLE ARE JUST TRANSIENT RIGHT.
THERE MIGHT BE PEOPLE WHO WHO
ARE MOVING HERE TO FILL A NEED
AND STAY HERE. I DON'T KNOW IF
WE HAVE THE DATA ON THAT RIGHT.
THERE MIGHT BE SOME PEOPLE WHO
WHO SAY HEY, GREAT. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO YOU KNOW TO COME,
SO I'M JUST MORE UM, HUSSEIN. I
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION AND I,
YOU KNOW, I'M LEARNING MORE
ABOUT THIS AND UNDERSTAND. YOU
KNOW, THEY APPRECIATED MORE KIND
OF THAT THAT BALANCE BETWEEN
PROTECTING OUR CONSUMERS AND
UPHOLD UNDER STANDARDS WHILE
MAKING SURE WE HAVE ENOUGH
PEOPLE TO FILL THESE HEROES.
THANK YOU. DID YOU HAVE A FOLLOW
UP COMMENT? OKAY? I JUST I WANT
TO SAY OR PIGGYBACKING ON A
COUPLE OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE
THAT COMPACTS AREN'T THE ONLY
STRATEGY FORWARD. YOU TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT RECIPROCITY.
AND I WOULD JUST YOU KNOW, IN A
TEMPORARY NEED. FOR ANY GROUP.
WHATEVER GROUP THAT MAYBE. YOU
JUST REMEMBER THAT COMPACT WOULD
BE REALLY HARD TO GET OUT OF
LATER. SO IF YOU'RE USING IT TO
ADDRESS A DIP IN SOMETHING AUTO
MECHANICS AS YOU STATED OR
SOMETHING ELSE, JUST REMEMBER
THAT WE WOULD WE WOULD STAY THAT
COMPACT EVEN AFTER WE FILL THAT
HOLE BECAUSE THESE ARE NOT EASY
TO GET OUT OF WHERE THERE'S
RECIPROCITY OR OTHER THINGS
WHERE THAT MIGHT MIGHT BE A
BETTER TOOL OR FOR DEALING WITH
A TEMPORARY LACK OF EMPLOYMENT
AREA AND THEN JUST FOR ME. I
JUST WANT TO SORT OF, SAY THIS
OUT LOUD. I THINK WHAT I HEAR
FROM A LOT OF MY COLLEAGUES IS
WHATEVER WE DO. WE PROBABLY NEED
TO LOOK AT THEM EACH
INDIVIDUALLY. RIGHT AND THEN
THINK ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S NEEDS
AND WHERE WE ARE NOT JUST RIGHT
NOW. BUT REALLY WHERE WE WHERE
WE WANT TO GO WITH IT ALL. DON'T
JUST MAKE A DECISION BASED ON
THE EXACT MOMENT THAT WE'RE IN.
AND WHAT I'M HEARING FROM YOU
ADDING SO MUCH DEPTH TO THIS
DIALOGUE IS TO MAKE SURE WE PUT
CONSUMERS IN THE EQUATION AND
THAT THEY'RE THEY HAVE A SEAT AT
THE TABLE THAT WE DON'T SEED
THAT POWER AND AUTHORITY TO
ANOTHER. GROUP OF FOLKS, NOT IN
CALIFORNIA THAT MAY OR MAY NOT
EVEN HAVE A CONSUMER FRAME FOR
LOOKING AT THE PROBLEMS. AND
ALSO THAT WE PROTECT THE
INTEGRITY OF THE PROFESSIONS,
THOUGH. I'M SURE THERE ARE MANY
GREAT PEOPLE WORKING IN THESE
LICENSES AREAS OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA. I DON'T THINK THAT'S
THE ARGUMENT. I THINK THE
ARGUMENT IS, ONCE THEY COME HERE
THAT WE DO HOLD THEM TO A
STANDARD AND THEN SORT OF THAT
VERY UNIQUE CALIFORNIA PIECE
THAT WE FIGURE OUT HOW WE HOLD
THOSE CALIFORNIA VALUES INSIDE
OF A COMPACT OR MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN BEFORE WE ENTER INTO ONE
THOSE THINGS THAT WE HOLD SO
DEAR HERE THAT WE FIGHT SO HARD
FOR SO THANK YOU FOR ADDING MUCH
TO THIS DIALOGUE. I DON'T SEE
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. GREATLY APPRECIATE
NOT JUST YOUR TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY, BUT THE WORK YOU DO FOR
US AND ON BEHALF OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS EVERY DAY WHEN YOU
COME TO WORK, AND YOU'RE YOU'RE
AMAZING TEAM. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR EVERYTHING THAT YOU'RE
DOING. NO, THANK YOU. ALRIGHT
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO OUR NEXT
SPEAKER, WHICH I BELIEVE IS OUR
FINAL SPEAKER, RIGHT? WE HAVE
TWO MORE SORRY. HOLD ON. YEAH,
YEAH. YEAH WE HAVE ONE FINAL
SPEAKER FOR OUR SORT OF
INFORMATIONAL PIECE. AND THEN
WHEN WE'RE DONE WITH THAT
SPEAKER WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON. OKAY. WE
INVITED HIM TO COME AND SHARE
SOME COMMENTS WITH US TODAY.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE. IF YOU'RE
OKAY, HANG OUT. WE HAVE ONE
SPEAKER BEFORE YOU. ANSWER OUR
NEXT SPEAKER IS LESLIE ROSTI.
SHE'S THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR THE
FUTURE OF THE BEAUTY INDUSTRY
COALITION. I THINK SHE SAID VERY
MUCH. SO YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
TURN YOUR NEXT A LITTLE BIT HERE
BECAUSE SHE'S WITH US VIA ZOOM.
AND WE THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
MS ROSTI, THANKS FOR TAKING SOME
TIME. GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT, SO
GOOD MORNING CHAIR ASHBY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR INTEREST IN BETTER
UNDERSTANDING THE COSMETOLOGY
INTERSTATE LICENSURE COMPACT
THAT IS CURRENTLY UNDER
CONSIDERATION IN YOUR COMMITTEE.
UM I REPRESENT THE FUTURE FUTURE
OF THE BEAUTY INDUSTRY COALITION
. IT'S A COLLECTIVE OF COMPANIES
THAT PROVIDE WHAT THEY STATE
BUSINESS SERVICES BUSINESSES
SUCH AS ALL TO J. C PENNEY,
SPORT CLIPS. GREAT CLIPS. UM,
YOU GET THE IDEA. UM I WAS ASKED
BY THIS COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS
SPECIFIC ASPECTS OF THE
COSMETOLOGY COMPACT, WHICH I
WILL TRY TO DO THE LOSS OF THE
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS SHOULD
YOU HAVE ANY AT THE END, HOWEVER
, FROM THE PREVIOUS TESTIMONY,
IT SOUNDS AS THOUGH THE
COSMETOLOGY COMPACT MAYBE A VERY
DIFFERENT THAN OTHER COMPACTS,
BOTH AN IMPLEMENTATION, SCOPE
AND IMPACT FOR CALIFORNIA. UM IN
PARTICULAR. THIS IS ONE LICENSE
WHERE LICENSING REQUIREMENTS ARE
ACTUALLY LOWER IN CALIFORNIA
THAN IN 45 OTHER STATES. UM
THAT'S NOT TO SAY I DON'T THINK
THAT THERE ARE ADEQUATE. THERE
JUST HAPPENED TO BE LOWER. UM,
AS OUR CSG PARTNER EXPLAINED,
THIS COMPACT IS CONSIDERED THE
GOLD STANDARD OF LICENSE
MOBILITY, ALLOWING LICENSES TO
MOVE SEAMLESSLY ACROSS STATE
LINES TO OTHER MEMBER STATES AND
SIMPLY CONTINUE TO WORK IN THIS
INDUSTRY, WHERE JOBS ARE
PLENTIFUL AND DAILY PAY ALLOWS
FOR A LICENSEE TO BE ABLE TO
IMMEDIATELY DO THINGS LIKE PAY
RENT AND BUY GROCERIES IN A
COMMUNITY. THEY MAY BE
CONSIDERING MOVING TO THIS TYPE
OF MOBILITY REALLY BENEFITS
LICENSES, INCLUDING CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS, WHO OFTEN NEED TO
WORK ACROSS STATE LINES
TEMPORARILY, SUCH AS WHEN A NEW
STORE IS OPEN. THERE ARE
SEASONAL NEEDS OR OTHER PERSONAL
REASONS THAT REQUIRE SOMEONE TO
WORK SOMEWHERE OTHER THAN WHERE
THEY'RE LICENSED FOR A TEMPORARY
TÌM. FOR THE INDUSTRY.
BUSINESSES IN YOUR STATE COMPACT
ALLOWS THEM TO DRAW FROM A
LARGER POOL OF POTENTIAL
EMPLOYEES WHEN OPENING NEW
STORES FILLING SEASONAL NEEDS
AND SIMPLY PUTTING SOMEONE TO
WORK IMMEDIATELY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, CURRENTLY TRANSFER
OF A LICENSE TO CALIFORNIA IS
DONE THROUGH A VERSION OF
UNIVERSAL LICENSING RECIPROCITY,
BASICALLY ALLOWING A TYPE OF
LICENSE A LICENSE FOR LICENSE
APPROACH. HOWEVER THIS IS NOT AS
EASY OR TIMELY AS IT MIGHT SEEM.
IT STILL REQUIRES AN APPLICANT
PRODUCED CERTIFICATION LETTERS
FROM ALL OTHER STATES IN WHICH
THEY HOLD A LICENSE BEFORE THE
CALIFORNIA APPLICATION IS EVEN
CONSIDERED. CALIFORNIA OBVIOUSLY
HAS NO CONTROL OVER HOW LONG IT
MAY TAKE ANOTHER STATE TO SEND
THESE, BUT IT GENERALLY TAKES
SEVERAL WEEKS. WHEN
CERTIFICATIONS ARE RECEIVED
UNTIL STILL TAKES TIME IN
CALIFORNIA TO PROCESS THAT
LICENSE APPLICATION. THE
TIMEFRAME CURRENTLY IS 4 TO 6
WEEKS TO RECEIVE A CALIFORNIA
LICENSE DURING WHICH SOMEONE
COULD NOT WORK LEGALLY IN THE
STATE AND WOULD NOT BE GAINFULLY
EMPLOYED. CALIFORNIA DOES NOT
OFFER TEMPORARY LICENSES FOR
COSMETOLOGY. HOWEVER THE COMPACT
IS INTENDED TO PROVIDE TEMPORARY
AUTHORIZATION TO PRACTICE THEIR
AND WOULD REQUIRE A LICENSEE TO
MAKE CALIFORNIA THEIR NEW HOME
STATE SHOULD THEY MOVE THEIR
DOMICILE TO THAT STATE TO STATE
MUCH LIKE YOU DO WITH YOUR
DRIVER'S LICENSE? WHEN YOU MOVE,
THERE ARE MANY BENEFITS TO
CALIFORNIA HAVE BECOMING A
MEMBER STATE. BUT LIKELY, THE
MOST IMPORTANT IS THE ABILITY TO
USE THE REQUIRED COMPREHENSIVE
DATABASE TO PROVIDE IMPROVED
ENFORCEMENT AND A REDUCTION AND
LICENSED FRAUD AND POTENTIAL
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. FOR EXAMPLE,
THERE IS CURRENTLY A NATIONAL
MULTI STATE REVIEW TAKING PLACE
REVOLVING AROUND BROAD AND
SIGNIFICANT COSMETOLOGY LICENSE
FOR FRAUD ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THIS REVIEW HAS BEEN SLOWED BY
THE INABILITY TO SHARE
INVESTIGATE GATE OF INFORMATION
BETWEEN STATES AND THE FACT THAT
THERE IS NO SINGLE REPOSITORY
FOR VALIDATED LICENSE
INFORMATION. THE COMPACT
DATABASE WOULD CHANGES BY
ALLOWING FOR IMMEDIATE
TRANSPARENCY OF A PARTICULAR
LICENSE HISTORY FROM ITS
INCEPTION. ANOTHER BENEFIT TO
CALIFORNIA SHOULD YOU ELECT TO
ENACT THIS COMPACT IS HAVING A
SEAT ON THE CHARTER COMMISSION
THAT WILL BE SEATED LATER THIS
YEAR. EACH MEMBER STATE WILL
HAVE A SEAT ON THE COMMISSION
ONGOING BUT THIS INITIAL
COMMISSION WILL BE UNIQUE IN
THAT IT WILL SET THE RULES AND
BYLAWS FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE COMPACT LEGISLATION. IT WILL
DO THOSE THINGS LIKE DETERMINE
WHAT NEEDS TO BE IN THE
DATABASE. WHAT TRIGGERS WHEN YOU
GET YOUR LICENSE CHANGED FOR
YOUR HOME STATE. SOME OF THE
THINGS WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
HERE IN THIS CONVERSATION. THAT
SAID IF CALIFORNIA DID NOT ENACT
THIS YEAR, THEY WOULD STILL HAVE
A SEAT ON THE COMMISSION WHEN
THEY DO ENACT BUT WOULD NOT HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE A PART OF
WRITING THE RULES AND BYLAWS
THAT WILL GUIDE THIS COMPACT IN
THE FUTURE. INCIDENTALLY
CHRISTIE UNDERWOOD, THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF COSMETOLOGY
BOARD, WAS A PART OF THE
DOCUMENT WRITING GROUPS FOR THIS
PARTICULAR COMPACT TO ENSURE
THAT THE LANGUAGE DEVELOPED
WOULD SUPPORT THE REQUIREMENTS
OF CALIFORNIA AS FAR AS COST TO
THE STATE OR THE BOARD.
CALIFORNIA WOULD CONTINUE TO
OFFER BOTH A MULTI A SINGLE
STATE LICENSE AND A MULTI STATE
LICENSE, THEY WOULD HAVE THE
OPTION. WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SET AN INCREASED COST FOR THE
MULTI STATE BENEFITS THAT WOULD
OFFSET ANY COST TO THE STATE OR
TO THE BOARD. IN TERMS OF
ENFORCEMENT. CALIFORNIA WOULD
HAVE AUTHORITY OVER MEMBER STATE
LICENSES WHILE PRACTICING IN THE
STATE. SO IF I COME TO YOUR
STATE, CALIFORNIA WOULD NOT ONLY
BE ABLE TO FULLY SANCTIONED
LICENSEE AS THEY WOULD THEIR OWN
LICENSES, BUT ALSO FLAGGED THEM
IN THE DATABASE SO THAT OTHER
STATES WOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE A
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING AND AROUND
ANY SPECIFIC LICENSEE OR LICENSE
NUMBER. COMPACT ALLOWS FOR
STATES TO CONDUCT JOINT
INVESTIGATIONS SUCH THAT
EVIDENCE COULD BE SHARED AND
ACTED UPON IMMEDIATELY AND
APPROPRIATELY IN THE CURRENT
REVIEW, DESCRIBED PREVIOUSLY THE
DISCUSSION AROUND ISSUES WITH
LICENSE FRAUD, BAD ACTORS AND
ONGOING ISSUES IS BEING DONE AS
A PHONE CALL OR AN EMAIL CHAIN
THAT ONLY ALLOWS FOR LIMITED
DISCLOSURE AND REQUIRES TIME
THAT STATE OFFICES OFTEN DO NOT
HAVE OFTEN BRINGING THESE
REVIEWS TO ACTUALLY A HALT OR
SLOWING THEM SIGNIFICANTLY. IN
ADDITION, DIFFERENT FROM
HEALTHCARE COMPACTS THAT HAVE
EXISTED FOR MANY YEARS, THIS
COMPACT EMBRACES AND IMPROVES
YOUR CURRENT OVERSIGHT EFFORTS.
FOR EXAMPLE, THERE IS NO ROUTINE
OVERSIGHT FOR NURSE. NO ONE
COMES INTO THE HOSPITAL TO SEE
IF THE NURSES WASH YOUR HANDS
BEFORE SHE TOUCHES A PATIENT.
HOWEVER IN COSMETOLOGY, BOTH
ROUTINE AND COMPLAINT BASED
INSPECTIONS OCCUR WHERE ANY
POTENTIAL CONCERNS WITH LICENSES
WOULD BE DISCOVERED, AND
AUTHORIZATION TO PRACTICE COULD
BE REVOKED. PROACTIVELY FINALLY,
THE COMPACT COMMISSION WILL FILL
A VOID IN TERMS OF THE SHARING
OF INFORMATION IN THE ABSENCE OF
A SINGLE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE INDUSTRY THAT
SO MANY OCCUPY OTHER OCCUPATIONS
BENEFIT FROM MEMBER STATES WILL
MEET TO DISCUSS COMPACT ISSUES
REGULARLY, BUT ALSO ISSUES THEY
HAVE IN COMMON AND STATES IS
DIVERSE AND LARGEST. CALIFORNIA
CERTAINLY COULD BENEFIT FROM THE
SHARING AND DISCUSSIONS AS THEY
WOULD MOST ALMOST CERTAINLY
APPLIED TO STATES WITH THIS MANY
LICENSES. IN TERMS OF THE
MILITARY SPOUSE ELIGIBILITY AS
WRITTEN ON THE STATE WEBSITE
DOES REFERENCE, THE NEED TO
PROVE THAT LICENSE IN GOOD
STANDING AND ALL ACTIVE AND
VALID OUT OF STATE LICENSES, AS
WELL AS USE OF THE ACTIVE
LICENSE AND IMMEDIATELY
PRECEDING YEARS. THESE ARE BOTH
TIME INTENSIVE PROCESSES FOR
MILITARY FAMILY LICENSES, WHO
MAY HOLD LICENSES IN MANY STATES
OR MAY HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO
UTILIZE THEIR LICENSE IN THE
PREVIOUS TWO YEARS. I BELIEVE
THAT IF CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO
ENTER INTO ANY OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSING COMPACT, THIS MAY BE
THE ONE THAT GIVES THEM THE MOST
CONTROL WITH THE LOWEST RISK.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HOW THEY ARE
ALL INDIVIDUALLY DIFFERENT, AND
I BELIEVE THIS ONE HAS A
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. GREAT
I'M SURE THERE WILL BE SOME
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES. LET
ME START BY SAYING THAT, UH
THERE ARE ABSOLUTELY PEOPLE THAT
GO INTO THE HOSPITALS AND WATCH
OUR NURSES AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY WASH THEIR HANDS AND FOLLOW
ALL PROPER PROCEDURES AND AS THE
WIFE OF A CLINICAL MANAGER FOR
OUR LARGEST ER IN SACRAMENTO. I
CAN'T GO HOME WITHOUT SAYING
THAT PUBLICLY. UM LET ME ASSURE
YOU, THE HOSPITALS ARE WELL
REGULATED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO THAT THAT THAT IS
AN INACCURATE STATEMENT. OKAY SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
AND FOR CHIMING IN, AND
PARTICULARLY ON THIS TOPIC. I
KNOW YOU WEREN'T HERE TO TALK
ABOUT HOSPITALS WITH US, SO NOT
HOLDING THAT AGAINST YOU. BUT I
DO WANT TO ASK YOU IF YOU HAVE A
SENSE OF HOW FREQUENTLY
CALIFORNIANS ARE LEAVING THE
STATE AND THEN UNABLE TO BECOME
LICENSED SOMEWHERE ELSE, AND, UH
, REALLY, AT THE ROOT OF MY
QUESTION IS WHO IN CALIFORNIA?
IS THIS DESIGNED TO HELP? I CAN
KIND OF HEAR FROM YOUR COMMENT
HOW IT WOULD HELP OTHER PEOPLE
COMING IN. HOWEVER WE IN THE
INFORMATION WE'VE RECEIVED.
THERE IS A BIT OF CONFLICT ABOUT
HOW LONG IT DOES TAKE FOR THAT
PROCESS IN TERMS OF COSMETOLOGY
FOR SOMEBODY COMING FROM STATE,
OREGON OR WHATEVER TO COME INTO
CALIFORNIA AND RECEIVE A LICENSE
TO GO AHEAD AND START MAKING A
LIVING. WE CERTAINLY DO WANT TO
STREAMLINE THAT. BUT CAN YOU
GIVE US AN IDEA? DO YOU HAVE A
THOUGHT ON THE OTHER HALF OF
THAT EQUATION, PEOPLE LEAVING
CALIFORNIA. YES AND 19 STATES,
UM IN 19, OTHER OF THE OTHER
STATES, CALIFORNIA COSMETOLOGIST
LICENSED COSMETOLOGIST WOULD
HAVE TO EITHER TAKE ADDITIONAL
HOURS OR REEXAMINED. SO TAKE
THEIR THEIR BOARD EXAM ALL OVER
AGAIN, OR PERHAPS BOTH. SO IN 19
STATES, IT WOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE AT THE
TIME RIGHT NOW. AND THOSE 19
STATES ARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMPACT. NOBODY COMPACT DOESN'T
STANDING YET. IT'S A NEW
COMPACT. WE ONLY HAVE THREE
STATES THAT HAVE ENACTED RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE WE HAVE LEGISLATION
PENDING IN 12 OTHER STATES, SO,
UM, RIGHT NOW, I CAN'T TELL YOU
WHO WILL BE IN IT WHEN IT
ACTUALLY IS STANDING KENTUCKY
AND ARIZONA IN RIGHT NOW AND
WRITE KENTUCKY, ARIZONA AND
ALABAMA ARE IN RIGHT NOW. OKAY?
SENATOR ROTH. SO JUST TO FOLLOW
UP. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR JUST
TO FOLLOW UP ON THIS, UM THE
INDIVIDUAL DOESN'T GET TO PICK
DOMICILE OR RESIDENCE. SO IF YOU
COME TO CALIFORNIA AND YOU MOVE
HERE, BEACONS DELIVERS YOUR
STUFF. AND YOU RENT OR BUY A
HOME OR LIVE WITH SOMEBODY ELSE
AND YOU WANT TO ESTABLISH YOUR
PLACE OF YOUR LIFE HERE AND YOUR
WORK HERE. AT SOME POINT YOU
BECOME A CALIFORNIA RESIDENT,
AND IT'S USUALLY AFTER SIX
MONTHS OR 12 MONTHS, AND YOU
CAN'T DRIVE ON YOUR USED GEORGIA
BECAUSE I WAS ORIGINALLY
LICENSED IN GEORGIA. YOU CAN'T
DRIVE ON YOUR GEORGIA DRIVER'S
LICENSE. YOU ULTIMATELY HAVE TO
PAY CALIFORNIA INCOME TAX. AND
SO I GUESS I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHO BENEFITS FROM THE
COMPACT AND IF IT'S IF IT'S.
EMPLOYEES OF A LARGER
CORPORATIONS IN THE BEAUTY
INDUSTRY THAT NEED TO MOVE
PEOPLE AROUND TEMPORARILY TO
COVER STAFFING NEEDS OR TRAINING
NEEDS. THEN WOULDN'T WE BE
BETTER OFF JUST FIXING THAT IN
OUR PRACTICE ACTUAL IF WE DON'T
ALREADY HAVE A PROVISION FOR IT
TO ALLOW TEMPLE, TEMPORARY
EMPLOYMENT OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE LICENSED IN SOME OTHER STATE
FOR THAT PURPOSE. BECAUSE IT
SEEMS TO ME IT'S THE TEMPORARY
EMPLOYEES. THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT HERE, NOT THOSE WHO ARE
RESIDENTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN MY IN MY RIGHT ON
THAT, MA'AM. SO TWO THINGS. ONE
IS WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT YOUR
PRESIDENCY. THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT THIS INITIAL
COMMISSION WOULD BE MAKING RULES
AROUND. WHEN DO YOU BECOME A
RESIDENT OF THE STATE? MUCH LIKE
YOUR MOTOR VEHICLE DEPARTMENT
DECIDED WHEN YOU HAVE TO GET A
NEW DRIVER'S LICENSE. THIS
COMPACT, THE COMMISSION WOULD
DECIDE. WHEN DOES SOMEBODY HAVE
TO GET A LICENSE? THIS BECOMES
THEIR HOME STATE. SO LET ME JUST
STOP YOU. YOU MEAN THE
COMMISSION IN THIS CASE, THE
COMMISSION WOULD ADOPT A RULE.
WHICH WAS MY POINT OF MY EARLIER
QUESTION WAS ONE OF THE OTHER
SPEAKERS. THE COMMISSION WHERE
CALIFORNIA HAS ONE VOTE WOULD
ADOPT A RULE TO ESTABLISH
DOMICILE OR RESIDENCY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, WHICH
IMPACTS DRIVER'S LICENSE
REQUIREMENTS AROUND THEIR
SPECIFIC TO THIS LICENSE
SPECIFIC TO THIS LICENSE, SO
WHEN WOULD THEY HAVE TO WHAT IS
THE TIME FRAME IN WHICH THEY
WOULD HAVE TO MAKE THIS THEIR
HOME STATE FOR THIS PARTICULAR
LICENSE WITH THAT, BUT STILL,
IT'S CALIFORNIA, WITH ONE VOTE
ON A ON A COMMISSION BOARD WHERE
CALIFORNIA HAS THE BULK OF THE
LICENSES AND THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA AT LEAST A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF THEM. AND
THE COMMISSION IS GOING TO MAKE
A RULE. TELLING CALIFORNIA AS A
MATTER OF LAW, WHO IS A RESIDENT
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. FOR
PURPOSES OF LICENSURE. ONLY
SPECIFIC TO THIS PARTICULAR
LICENSE THAT YOU'VE ENTERED INTO
THIS COMPACT ON THIS COSMETOLOGY
LICENSE. AND IF WE IF WE
SUBSEQUENTLY DON'T LIKE THAT,
THEN IT REQUIRES A MAJORITY OF
THE LEGISLATURES OF THE MEMBER
STATES. TO EITHER REVOKE THE
RULE OR CALIFORNIA'S LEGISLATURE
TO PASS A BILL AND A STATUTE TO
EXTRACT ITSELF FROM THE COMPACT.
THAT I DON'T KNOW. I'M NOT. I'M
NOT AN ATTORNEY ON HOW THIS THAT
PIECE OF IT WOULD WORK. THAT
MIGHT BE MORE APPROPRIATE
QUESTION FOR DAN. WELL, LET ME
GO BACK TO MY QUESTION. WHY, IF,
IN FACT THE TARGET AUDIENCE HERE
R AND I, IT COULD APPLY TO ANY
NUMBER OF COMPACTS, NOT JUST
THIS ONE. IF THE TARGET AUDIENCE
, UM IS THAT GROUP OF LICENSES
WHO EITHER WANT TO OR THEIR
EMPLOYER WANTS THEM TO, OR WE
NEED THEM TO COME INTO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE, UM,
SERVICES WITHIN THE SCOPE OF
THEIR PRACTICE. THEIR OCCUPATION
. WHY WHY WOULDN'T WE WANT TO DO
THAT? JUST IN TERMS OF A CHANGE
TO OUR PRACTICE ACT TO ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS TO COME IN
TEMPORARILY AND DO THAT WORK AS
OPPOSED THE BROADER ISSUE. YEAH
THAT COULD BENEFIT PEOPLE COMING
INTO YOUR STATUS THAT THAT THAT
WAS A DECISION THAT WAS MADE. IT
DEFINITELY DOESN'T BENEFIT THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
EVIDENCE OF CALIFORNIA WHO MAY
ALSO HAVE TO DO THOSE THINGS.
WELL THE ONE THING THAT STRIKES
ME AS WE'VE HAD HEARINGS, I
ASSUME WELL, NO, I SPENT A FAIR
AMOUNT OF TIME DEALING WITH
BARBERS AND COSMETOLOGISTS OR
TWO AGO. UM I DON'T REMEMBER
ANYBODY COMING IN. AND MAYBE,
YOU KNOW, I'M. MY MEMORY MAY BE
FAULTY, BUT I DON'T REMEMBER ANY
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS COMING IN TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT PORTABILITY GOING
OUTSIDE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE COMPLAINTS WERE MUCH
DIFFERENT IN MY WRONG UM, I WAS
IN THE PREVIOUS CONVERSATIONS
WHEN WE TALKED IN TERMS OF
BARBERINI COSMETOLOGY. I DON'T
REALLY RECALL THERE BEING ANY
SIGNIFICANT CONVERSATION AROUND
LICENSE PORTABILITY SO THAT MY
NAME MAY BE MY MEMORY. IN THIS
CASE THAT MADE IT WAS NOT
SIGNIFICANT ABOUT LICENSE
PORTABILITY. BUT ARGUABLY, YOU
KNOW, YOU HAVE SAID THAT YOU
HAVE THE MOST NUMBER OF LICENSES
IN THE UNITED STATES. SO IF IT'S
AN ISSUE IN OTHER STATES, IT'S
EVEN A BIGGER ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR PEOPLE NEEDING TO
GO AND DO OTHER THINGS. SO IF
IT'S AN ISSUE IN A STATE OF
SMALL AS YOU KNOW, DELAWARE IT'S
OUR MULTIPLE TIMES IS BIG IN
CALIFORNIA THAT PEOPLE MIGHT
HAVE TO GO AND DO SOMETHING
TEMPORARILY IN ANOTHER STATE.
WELL, THAT'S MY POINT. I MEAN,
IT'S THE TEMPORARY PERSON WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. AND ISN'T THERE
ANOTHER WAY TO DEAL WITH THE UM,
TEMPORARY WORK ISSUE, UM,
OUTSIDE OF A COMPACT, SO WE
DON'T HAVE TO GET INTO HOW WE
GET INTO THIS THING. HOW WE GET
OUT OF THE THING. WHAT? WHAT IS
QUALIFIED IMMUNITY MEAN? UH HUH.
HOW WE ASSESS FEES? UM DATA
PROTECTION AND ALL THE OTHER
ISSUES THAT WERE IDENTIFIED WITH
THE PRIOR SPEAKER. I THINK THE
PROBLEM IS THERE'S 49 OTHER
STATES RIGHT AND GETTING ALL THE
49 OTHER STATES TO AGREE. MAKES
IT YOU YOU ALREADY HAVE IN THIS
INDUSTRY. YOU ALREADY HAVE A
COMPLETE, UM I DON'T WANT TO SAY
HODGEPODGE, BUT A, UM IT ACROSS
STATE LINES. IT IS VERY
DIFFERENT. IT IS VERY
COMPLICATED. HOW LIFE LOOK HOW
LICENSED HOW YOU GET LICENSE,
RECIPROCITY, HOW YOU TRANSFER
LICENSE, AND THAT MAY NOT BE
TRUE. ANOTHER INDUSTRY, OTHER
INDUSTRIES MAY HAVE A MORE
STRAIGHTFORWARD APPROACH TO BUT
IN THIS INDUSTRY IF YOU LIVE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, AND YOU
WANT TO GO TO ANOTHER STATE, IT
MAY BE EXTREMELY COMPLICATED
TIME CONSUMING TIME THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE. AND SO I GET WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING ABOUT MAKING IT A
TEMPORARY THING. BUT HOW DO WE
GET ALL THE OTHER STATES TO
AGREE THAT WHEN SOMEONE WANTS TO
LEAVE CALIFORNIA THE PEOPLE YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WANT TO LEAVE THAT
THEY CAN ACTUALLY WORK. RIGHT?
THERE'S NO MECHANISM FOR THAT,
AND THIS IS THE BEST MECHANISM.
YOU KNOW THAT I THAT THERE IS AT
THIS MOMENT RIGHT FOR
BIDIRECTIONAL MOBILITY. WELL,
WE'RE INTERESTED IN THAT, OF
COURSE, BUT OUR PRIMARY CONCERN
IS WHAT HAPPENS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND HOW WE PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND HOW WE GIVE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES TO
THOSE WHO WISH TO UM, CONTINUE
TO LIVE HERE. THOSE WHO WISH TO
MOVE HERE AND PROVIDE WORK HERE
AND ALSO THOSE WHO ARE PROVIDING
A SERVICE ON BEHALF OF THEIR
EMPLOYERS, WHICH WAS THE POINT
OF MY QUESTION. IF THIS IS AN
EMPLOYER ISSUE, HOW CAN WE
ACCOMMODATE EMPLOYERS WHO DO
BUSINESS HERE TO FACILITATE THE
TEMPORARY MOVEMENT OF EMPLOYEES
FROM ONE STATE INTO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO COVER STAFFING
NEEDS TRAINING NEEDS AND ALL THE
REST AND I'D BE INTERESTED IN
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION, BUT
I'M SURE MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR
DODD IS GOING TO TELL ME. I'VE
EXHAUSTED MY TIME. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. CAN MAKE ONE
COMMENT ON THAT. WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY EVERY THE
COMPACT REQUIRES AN EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM, AND IT ALSO REQUIRES
LICENSURE EXAM THAT THE PEOPLE
TAKE A LICENSURE EXAM. THE
LICENSES COMPLETE ONE AND BOTH
NATIONAL EXAMS ARE WIDELY BASED
ON HEALTH AND PUBLIC SAFETY, SO
THAT ISSUE OF NOT BEING SAFE IN
CALIFORNIA SOMEONE COMING IN
FROM ANOTHER STATE. UM YOU'RE
GETTING LICENSED PEOPLE THAT YOU
ALREADY SAID. THEY JUST SHOW UP
AND YOU GIVE THEM A LICENSE. SO
YOU KNOW IF THAT LICENSE
RECOGNITION PIECE YOU'RE ALREADY
GIVING SOMEONE A LICENSE FROM
ANOTHER STATE, SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU UNDERSTAND
THAT PEOPLE WOULD BE SAFE
WORKING IN YOUR STATE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
RESPONSE. I AGREE. YEAH ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS, SENATOR BECKER. THANKS
TO GET CLEAR ON THE TIMEFRAME
CURRENTLY THAT IT TAKES TO GIVE
SOMEONE A LICENSE FROM OUT OF
STATE. I THINK WE HAVE THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FROM THE
BOARD. HMM MAYBE COULD COULD
COMMENT QUICKLY. IF IT'S THAT'S
GREAT. YES, PLEASE. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE. THERE WOULD
EXECUTIVE OFFICER WITH THE BOARD
AND WE ARE CURRENTLY RUNNING AT
THREE WEEKS FOR SOMEBODY COMING
INTO CALIFORNIA TO GET A LICENSE
HAD SOME VACANCY ISSUES IN OUR
OFFICE, UM, FULLY STAFFED, SO
WE'LL SEE WHERE THAT GOES. BUT
ABOUT 3 TO 4 WEEKS RIGHT NOW,
GOT IT VERY HELPFUL. THANK YOU.
CAN YOU WALK US THROUGH THAT
START TO FINISH? SO THREE WEEKS
THEY COME IN. THEY LET YOU KNOW
THEY JUST MOVED HERE. YES SO
THEY FILL OUT AN APPLICATION
MOST COMMONLY ONLINE. THEY HAVE
TO GET A CERTIFICATION LETTER
FROM THE STATE WHERE THEY'RE
LICENSED. THAT COMES IN
SEPARATELY. WE ONLY ACCEPT THAT
FROM THE ACTUAL OTHER STATE, SO
THOSE COME IN SEPARATELY. WE
MIRROR THOSE TWO TOGETHER, AND
THEN WE APPROVE THAT APPLICATION
AND THAT INDIVIDUAL MUST GO PICK
UP THEIR LICENSE. FROM ONE OF
OUR TESTING FACILITIES SO THAT
THEIR PHOTOGRAPH AND
IDENTIFICATION CAN BE VERIFIED.
AND YOU SAID WITH VACANCIES HERE
AT THREE WEEKS, THAT SOUNDS LIKE
MAYBE IT'S A LITTLE LONGER THAN
USUAL. WHAT IS IT NORMALLY? IT'S
WHEN WE FIRST IMPLEMENTED SP 803
WITH, UM LICENSE. WE'RE
BASICALLY LICENSED FOR LICENSE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. IT WAS WE
WERE DOWN TO LESS THAN A WEEK.
SO YOU'RE ARRANGES SOMEWHERE
UNDER A WEEK TO ABOUT THREE
WEEKS, RIGHT? GOT IT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD CALL SENATOR
BECKER. DID YOU HAVE OTHER
QUESTIONS? OKAY? LET ME JUST ASK
ONE QUICK ONE. YOU KNOW IF THE
CONCERN IS WE HAVE CORPORATE
OPERATORS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE THAT EMPLOY
COSMETOLOGISTS AND THEY ARE IN
OTHER STATES, AND THERE ARE
SPECIFIC, UNIQUE ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH TRAINING OR
MAYBE PRIMARILY TRAINING OF
OTHERS SETTING UP OFFICES OR
MAYBE STAFFING. THE SHORTAGES. I
SUPPOSE WE COULD TAKE A LOOK
INSIDE THE PRACTICE ACT TO SEE
IF THERE COULD BE SPECIFIC CARVE
OUTS AND PROVISIONS OR
PROCEDURES TO ALLOW THOSE
INDIVIDUALS TO COME INTO THE
STATE AND PRACTICE THEIR
OCCUPATION. THERE DEFINITELY
COULD BE, UM ARE MY BOARD DOES
SUPPORT THE COSMETOLOGY COMPACT?
I DID WORK ON IT AS IT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER. UM WE DO
THINK THAT I'VE BEEN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
FOR CLOSE TO 30 YEARS. UM AND I
DO THINK THAT THIS IS A COMPACT
THAT IS A LITTLE MORE FRIENDLY
TO OUR TO OUR LICENSES. UM IT'S
COSMETOLOGY COSMETOLOGY AMONG
THE STATES. I DON'T KNOW THAT I
WOULD BE SAYING THAT IF I WORKED
FOR ONE OF OUR ALLIED HEALTH
BOARDS, BUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THERE IS A STRONG LINE OF STATES
THAT HAVE THE SAME SCOPE OF
PRACTICE. WE DO HAVE SOME
LIMITATIONS ON SOME STATES. BUT
THE OUR BOARD DOES SUPPORT THE
COSMETOLOGY COMPACT. AND OF
COURSE, YOU HEARD MY COMMENTS. I
THINK THERE'S SOME UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES BY UM. MOST OF US
WOULDN'T SIGN A CONTRACT IF IT
WAS COMPLICATED WITHOUT GETTING
LEGAL REVIEW AND ADJUSTING THE
TERMS AND PROVISIONS TO FIT OUR
PARTICULAR CIRCUMSTANCES.
UNFORTUNATELY IN THE COMPACT
ARENA AS IT'S CURRENTLY.
OPERATING IT DOESN'T SEEM TO
WORK THAT WAY. THANK YOU.
WELCOME BEFORE YOU WALK AWAY.
LET ME ASK YOU ONE MORE
QUESTIONS JUST BECAUSE THIS CAME
UP ON SOME OF THE OTHERS. IS
THIS AN AREA WHERE WE HAVE A
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL PEOPLE IN
THE COSMETOLOGY SPACE OR HOW
MANY LICENSES DO WE HAVE ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA? MY
BOARD LICENSES 621,000
INDIVIDUALS IN THE COSMETOLOGY
AREA. WE ARE AT ABOUT 230,000
INDIVIDUALS. GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANKS FOR LETTING US
PUT YOU ON THE HOT SEAT. ALRIGHT
I THINK THAT'S IT FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. SO WE THANK YOU TO
EVERYBODY WHO WHO COMMENTED
THERE AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S GIBSON COME ON
UP AND SHARE A FEW THOUGHTS WITH
US. OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A BROAD
INFORMATIONAL HEARING YOU CAN
YOU WANT TO SIT AT THE TABLE OR
YOU WANT TO STAND UP AND DO
WHATEVER YOU WANT MOST
COMFORTABLE THERE, OKAY? WELCOME
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S. THANKS FOR
JOINING US. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND I WANT TO
ALSO PAUSE AND THINK I'M SENATOR
ROTH FOR ONE. I WAS IN HIS
OFFICE AND WE HAD A VERY ROBUST
CONVERSATION THAT HAS LED TO US
COMING TOGETHER TO GATHER TO
HAVE THIS INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
THANK YOU. AND CONGRATULATIONS
TO YOU AND YOUR CHAIRMAN. YOUR
CHAIR SHIP, UM AND MOVING THIS
CONVERSATION FOR SO I'M VERY
EXCITED TO BE HERE. I WANT TO
THANK ALL THOSE WHO I'VE SPOKEN.
THUS FAR, I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT ON THIS
ON THIS TOPIC. UM, AND THE WORK
OF THE OF THIS COMMITTEE, UM,
UNDER THE FORMER CHAIRS, I
INDICATED, UM, TO EXPLORE
CALIFORNIA'S CONSIDERATION ON
THE INTERSTATE COMPACT. I
CURRENTLY SERVE AS THE VICE
CHAIR OF CSG WEST. I WAS
IMMEDIATE PAST PRESIDENT OF C S
OF C S G. WELL, EXCUSE ME NOW I
SERVED ON THE NATIONAL COMMITTEE
AS VICE CHAIR OF CSG. UM
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA, IS A MEMBER OF THAT
ORGANIZATION, WHICH IS A
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION AND
BECAUSE I SERVED AS CSG WEST
OFFICER FOR SUCH A LONG TIME, IT
HAS LED US TO THE HAVING THIS
ROBUST CONVERSATION THAT TALKS
ABOUT A COMPACT. THAT'S THE
SUBJECT OF THIS. TOPIC TODAY.
THE ORGANIZATION NATURALLY
FACILITATES THE EXCHANGE OF
IDEAS AND EXPERIENCES THAT'S AND
BEST PRACTICES ON POLICIES THAT
STATES GOVERNANCE. AND UM, YOU
HEARD FROM THESE WITNESSES ON
EXTENSIVE STUDIES AND TALKING
ABOUT THE PROS AND CONS OF
INTERSTATE COMPACT ACROSS MANY
DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES. SOME OF
YOU MAY KNOW THAT I HAVE A BILL
THAT BILL IS BEING SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
BARBERING CAUSE. OF TOLERANCE.
TO ESTABLISH A STATE COSMETOLOGY
COMPACT FOR OUR CURRENT
COSMETOLOGY WORKFORCE. INCOMING
COMIC COME UP. I'LL GET THERE,
COSMETOLOGIST, SCUSE ME AND
MILITARY FAMILIES WHO HAVE
LICENSES IN THIS SPACE AND
THAT'S ONE OF POSSIBLE MOMENT.
JUST TAKE NOTE THAT FORMER
SPEAKER KAREN BASS WHEN SHE WAS
A SPEAKER OF THIS CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY, UH, MADE IT HER
0.2 ALSO CORRECT AND MODIFY THIS
SPACE BECAUSE MANY OF YOU KNOW
THAT THOSE WHO HAVE WHO HAVE
BEEN CONVICTED WHO SERVED TIME
IN PRISON IN JAIL, THEY GET OUT.
LEARN A TRADE COME BACK AND THEY
COULD NOT GET LICENSED IN THIS
SPACE, AND IT WAS HER JOB TO
MAKING SURE THAT THE BOARD OF
COSMETOLOGY AND BARBERING TAKE A
CASE BY CASE BASIS. ENSURE THAT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
DEVELOPED THIS SCALE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME
ENTREPRENEURS IN OUR COMMUNITY,
AND MOST OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
HAS CERTAINLY HAVE BEEN PEOPLE
OF COLOR. AND SO I THINK, YOU
KNOW, ARE NOW MAYOR OF THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY, IN ADDITION TO THAT
IN THE MOVIE INDUSTRY, UM WHEN
AN INDIVIDUAL FOLLOWS AN ACTOR
OR AN ACTRESS OR SINGER, AND
THEY DO THEIR MAKEUP AND THINGS
OF THAT NATURE, THAT LICENSE HAS
TO COME HERE. SO THEY CAN
PERFORM THAT KIND OF SERVICE TO
THAT INDIVIDUALS. WE HAVE HEARD
FROM MANY OF THE BENEFITS THIS
COMPACT WILL PROVIDE FOR
COSMETOLOGY WORKFORCE, AND I'M
EXCITED TO WORK WITH YOU ALL ON,
HOPEFULLY ADVANCING THIS WORK IN
THIS LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
HOWEVER I UNDERSTAND THAT NOT
ALL COMPACTS ARE CREATED THE
SAME WAY I WANT TO UNDERSCORE
THAT NOT ALL COMPACTS ARE
TREATED THE SAME WAY EACH
INDUSTRY HAS ITS OWN UNIQUE
CHALLENGES, ENSURING PUBLIC
HEALTH AND CONSUMER SAFETY AND
PROTECTION SHOULD BE AT
THEREFORE FRONT OF OUR MINDS IN
CONSIDERING A COMPACT ACROSS
VARIOUS INDUSTRIES, AND IT IS
OUR JOB TO THOROUGHLY EVALUATE
EACH COMPACT ON ITS OWN MERITS
AND DETERMINE HOW CALIFORNIA CAN
ENGAGE, AND I WANT TO ALSO
UNDERSCORE THAT THE CHAIR UM
MEMBER MADE MENTIONED THAT A LOT
OF CALIFORNIA A LOT OF PEOPLE
WANT TO INVITE CALIFORNIA IN, UM
AND BEING PART OF THESE CONTACTS
, AND I THINK FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS, THIS PACIFIC THIS VERY
SPECIFIC REASON IS VERY UNIQUE
IS VERY FOCUSED ON THE BARBERING
COSMETOLOGY WORLD, AND WE ALSO
WANT TO UNDERSCORE THOSE WHO ARE
MILITARY WIVES AND UNDERSTAND
THAT THROUGH THE PREVIOUS
DIALOGUE UM, THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS MADE SOME
ALLOWANCES, BUT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THOSE ALLOWANCES MEETS OUR
STANDARDS. AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S THE REASON WHY THIS BILL
THAT I HAVE IS SPONSORING MAKING
SURE THAT WE ALLOW THIS TO
HAPPEN THAT MIRRORS. UM
CERTAINLY FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TAKES A LONG TIME IN THAT
PARTICULAR SPACE, AND WE HOPE TO
CREATE IN THIS SPACE WITH THIS
PARTICULAR INTERSTATE. IT
CREATES EQUITY ACROSS THE ENTIRE
BOARD. I AM CONFIDENT THAT THE
TESTIMONIES PROVIDED TODAY. AND
HERE HELPS EDUCATE US ALL A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS PARTICULAR
SUBJECT MATTER, BOTH POSITIVELY
AND NEGATIVELY. THOSE PARTICULAR
POINTS HAVE COME OUT AND I WANT
TO UNDERSCORE IT WOULD HAVE COME
OUT IF YOU HAD WE NOT HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THIS ROBUST
CONVERSATION, AND IT'S GOOD THAT
WE CAN PARTNER WITH OTHER STATES
IN THERE ARE IN THIS PARTICULAR
COMPACT. MY HOPE TODAY IS TO
HERE IN THIS HEARING WILL ADD
VALUE TO LEGISLATIVE
CONVERSATION. WE ANTICIPATE THIS
SESSION TO HELP US AND TO BETTER
INFORM IN OUR DECISION MAKING
PROCESS TO CONSIDER ESTABLISHING
COMPACT, WHICH IS AN A VERY
INAPPROPRIATE, UM, POINT TO
UNDERSCORE IN THIS CONVERSATION,
SO I WANT TO THANK THIS
COMMITTEE. THANK THE CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING GETS A FEW WORDS TO
JUST MAKE COMMENTS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SOME WOMEN JUST TO BE CLEAR.
THIS HEARING IS MUCH BROADER
THAN ONE BILL HIS HIS BILL WILL
HAVE ITS DAY. IT'LL BE
APPROPRIATELY NOTICED, AND
PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE TO COME AND
SPEAK AND ALL THOSE THINGS BUT
BECAUSE THIS TOPIC WAS PROVIDING
A BASELINE OF DISCUSSION FOR
SOMETHING WE KNOW IS COMING. WE
WANTED TO WELCOME HIM HERE. SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT. AND FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. THANK YOU.
OKAY THAT IS IT FOR OUR SPEAKERS
. WE DO HAVE A FEW MOMENTS HERE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. WE'RE GONNA
I ASKED FOLKS TO BE BRIEF AND
SUCCINCT, BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR FROM YOU THANKS FOR BEING
HERE WITH US. IF THERE'S ANYONE
WHO HAS A COMMENT, PLEASE LINE
UP HERE AT THE MIC, AND WE'LL
HEAR FROM YOU QUICKLY. GO RIGHT
AHEAD. JUST GIVE US THE NAME AND
ORGANIZATION THEN YOU'RE VERY
BRIEF COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT. AH
THANK YOU. CHAIR PERSON, ASHBY,
SENATOR ROTH AND, UM, COMMISSION
. EXCUSE ME. COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS KATHY KENNEDY,
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION REGISTERED
NURSE OF 44 YEARS, AND I'M ALSO
A COUNCIL MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH WORKFORCE,
EDUCATION AND TRAINING. COUNCIL
CNN HAS LONG OPPOSED THE NURSE
LICENSURE COMPACT BECAUSE IT
WOULD DO HARM BOTH TO OUR
PATIENTS AND OUR PROFESSION.
NURSES WITH MULTI STATE LICENSE
DO NOT HAVE TO MEET OUR STATE'S
HIGH BAR FOR CLINICAL EDUCATION
AND CONTINUING EDUCATION,
INCLUDING OUR REQUIREMENT OF 500
HOURS OF DIRECT PATIENT CARE,
CLINICAL HOURS. IMPLICIT BIAS
EDUCATION. THIS LOWERING THE
STANDARDS FOR NURSING EDUCATION
AND PRACTICE. THIS OPERATION
NIGHT NIGHTINGALE SCANDAL
UNDERSCORES THE DANGERS OF THE
NURSING COMPACT, FOR EXAMPLE,
OVER 7600 FRAUDULENT NURSING
DIPLOMAS WERE ISSUED IN FLORIDA,
WHICH IS A COMPACT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WAS A COMPACT STATE,
WE WOULD HAVE BEEN REQUIRED TO
ACCEPT FLORIDA'S LOWER EDUCATION
STANDARDS AND MAY HAVE
DANGEROUSLY ALLOWED IMPROPERLY
TRAINED INDIVIDUALS TO PRACTICE
AT OUR STATE. THE NURSE COMPACT
IS A DELIBERATE STEP. TO
DEREGULATE NURSING PROFESSION,
AND IT LAYS THE GROUNDWORK FOR
VIRTUAL NURSING ACROSS STATE
LINES AS YOU HEARD WHEN THEY
TALKED ABOUT TELEHEALTH. COMPACT
WOULD ALLOW EMPLOYERS TO RACE TO
THE BOTTOM SHIFTING NURSING JOBS
OUTSIDE OF OUR STATE, USING THE
CHEAPEST LABOR WITH THE LOWEST
STAFFING STANDARDS, THUS
THREATENING A NURSE'S ABILITY TO
ADVOCATE FOR OUR PATIENTS AND
FOR BETTER WORKING CONDITIONS,
SO WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
REJECT THIS IDEA OF A NURSE
LICENSURE COMPACT. AND INSTEAD
FOCUS ON CREATING AND PRESERVING
THE GOOD NURSING JOBS AND
SUPPORTING THE BEER IN AND
MAINTAINING CALIFORNIA'S HIGH
STANDARDS AND NURSING EDUCATION,
LICENSURE AND PRACTICE. THANK
YOU. GREAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND THANK YOU FOR
SITTING THROUGH THE WHOLE
HEARING. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU, UH, CARE
ASHBY AND WELCOME UM I'M LEAGUE
REGULATORY POLICY SPECIALIST
CARMEN COME SEE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
WITH RESPECT TO REGISTERED
NURSES COMPACT RELATIONS TOUR IS
NOT ONLY DANGEROUS FOR PATIENTS
AND THE NURSING PROFESSION, BUT
IT HAS NOT BEEN AN EFFECTIVE
TOOL AND RETAINING AND
RECRUITING OUR END IN OUR STATE,
THE ASSERTED BENEFITS OF COMPACT
LIGHT AND SURE FOR NURSES SIMPLY
HAVE NOT MATERIALIZED IN COMPACT
STATES. MANY COMPACT STATES HAVE
EXPERIENCED DECREASES IN NURSES
SINCE 2020 DURING THE HEIGHT OF
THE PANDEMIC. TEXAS LOUISIANA,
NEBRASKA, TENNESSEE, ALL COMPACT
STATES REPORTED NURSE STAFFING
SHORTFALLS AND COMPARING FEDERAL
DATA FROM COMPACT STATES WITH
NON COMPACT STATES. HIGHER
PERCENT OF HOSPITALS IN COMPACT
STATES. REPORT CRITICAL STAFFING
SHORTAGES ON AN AVERAGE ANNUAL
BASIS. IN CONTRAST, CALIFORNIA
IN 2021 WITHOUT NEEDING. NURSE
LICENSURE COMPACT ISSUED 29%
MORE LICENSES TO OUT OF STATE.
RN ARE AN APPLICANT AND GRANTED
OVER 1100 TEMPORARY LICENSES AND
THE DILIGENT WORK OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSES IS MAKING THE
RN LICENSURE BY ENDORSEMENT
PROCESS MORE EFFICIENT WHILE
MAINTAINING CALIFORNIA'S HIGH
STANDARDS AND EDUCATION,
TRAINING AND LICENSURE. TO
RECRUIT AND RETAIN NURSES AT THE
BEDSIDE, BUT LEGISLATURE CAN
SUPPORT SAFE STAFFING A RANT
STATE SAFE STAFFING FOR OUR
RENT, STRONG WORKPLACE HEALTH
AND SAFETY PROTECTIONS AND GOOD
UNION JOBS. WE CAN SHARE MORE
DATA WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
THANK YOU FOR THIS HEARING. GOOD
STATS. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU. CHAIR
ASHBY AND SENATOR ROTH FOR THE
EVER MOST ROBUST DISCUSSION
TODAY, JACKIE HONEST WITH
SLOGANS JENSEN AND ASSOCIATES ON
BEHALF OF TELADOC HEALTH WILL
BACKGROUND TELADOC HEALTH IS THE
WORLD'S LARGEST TELEHEALTH
PROVIDER, DELIVERING HEALTHCARE
AND 175 COUNTRIES AND MORE THAN
40 LANGUAGES JUST WANTED TO
QUICKLY HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE
OF LICENSE PORTABILITY AND THE
MENTAL HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
SPACE. OBVIOUSLY, CALIFORNIA IS
SUFFERING FROM A SHORTAGE OF
MENTAL HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS.
ONE STATISTIC TO REALLY
UNDERSCORE THIS POINT FROM THE
COUNTY BABY BEHAVIOR. HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION MORE THAN
90 COUNTIES HAVE REPORTED
DIFFICULTY IN RECRUITING
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS
AND LICENSED MARRIAGE AND FAMILY
COUNSELORS. THIS BRINGS US THE
IMPORTANCE OF, UH, LICENSE
REPORT ABILITY FOR OUT OF STATE
PRISON PROVIDERS TO PROTECT THE
PRACTICE VIA TELEHEALTH. AH WE
TALKED ABOUT TODAY. PORTABILITY
GROWS THE PIE PROVIDERS. WE GET
MORE ROBUST NETWORK AND SHORTER
WAIT TIMES FOR PATIENTS AND
THOSE WHO NEED CARE AND LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION AND SENATOR
DATI HIMSELF POINTED OUT TODAY
THAT, YOU KNOW, ASSESSING
RECIPROCITY AND OCCUPATIONS
FACING A SHORTAGE OF WORKFORCE
SHOULD BE A PRIORITY AND
OBVIOUSLY I JUST HIGHLIGHTED
MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE. THERE'S
A CLEAR SHORTAGE THERE. WE HAVE
12 OTHER STATES THAT HAVE SOME
LEVEL OF LICENSE RECIPROCITY
OUTSIDE OF COMPACTS. THE INCLUDE
MINNESOTA, DELAWARE AND
CONNECTICUT. SO AGAIN APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION HERE TODAY AND
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. ANYBODY ELSE? ALL
RIGHT. LOOKS LIKE WE'RE DONE
WITH OUR FIRST HEARING. OR AT
LEAST MY FIRST HEARING AS YOUR
CHAIR. THANK YOU FOR AND SENATOR
OFF. THANKS FOR STAYING WITH ME.
APPRECIATE YOU ALL RIGHT? THAT'S
IT. WE'LL GET IT DONE ANYTHING
WE NEEDED. WE'RE ADJOURNED.
THANKS, YOU GUYS.